[Music]
have your attention please
make sure
food allowed and no chewing
any gum so if you have any chewing gum
get rid of that please no chewing
chewing gum
so where you're sitting right now is
going to be your seat for the rest of
the day
so
correct thank you
so where you're sitting right now is
where you're going to be after lunch and
after breaks and nobody's fighting for
new spots after lunch
this is going to be where you're sitting
for the rest of the day okay
we don't want any problems with trying
to run in here after lunch and get
closer seats so this is it
uh
so
so uh when the judge
nope
oh
foreign
[Music]
all right good morning
do we have any preliminary matters
before the jury comes out
okay all right sure
yes sir
um
all right we're ready for the jury then
okay
good morning
all right
good morning ladies and gentlemen all
right
as you remember we were in the middle of
a witness last evening so we'll continue
with her testimony okay
thank you
did you see miss heard shortly after she
returned from australia
yes
how soon after she arrived back in
australia did you see her
i believe it was immediately upon her
return
and she visited you in your apartment at
the eastern columbia building is that
right
yes
you testified that you observed injuries
on this herd on this occasion is that
right
yes
what injuries did you observe
she had these deep cuts
on the backs of her forearms
and um
yeah they were very very deep long
cuts on the backs of her forearms
[Music]
did you see her feet
um at first when she came over she had
shoes on
and then um and then she showed me her
feet yeah
what specifically do you recall seeing
on mister's feet
they were just um
they were cut it was smaller cuts than
the ones on her
arms
were both feet
hot
i don't remember if it was both or one
you testified that mr told you that she
got these injuries from glass from
broken bottles is that correct
um
yes
you were not in australia with misheard
when she allegedly sustained these
injuries is that correct ms pennington
i was not in australia
but your only understanding as to how
mature sustained these injuries is what
she told you right
that is my understanding
you've testified that you attended a
thanksgiving dinner with mr deaf and
misheard in november of 2015. is that
correct
yes
and this dinner was held in penthouse 5
at the eastern columbia building right
um
yes
and and just to for clarification um
penthouse five was not mr jeff and mrs
primary residence correct
all of the
penthouses are connected
mr depp and miss heard lived in
penthouse 3. is that correct
well technically they lived in all of
them they were all connected
where did they have their rent their
bedroom
which penthouse
their bedroom was in
three
who attended this thanksgiving dinner
i think that
well josh myself
amber
johnny
there were a couple of johnny's friends
um i think amber's dad was there
jack johnny's son
i don't remember anyone else
specifically
you recall what time you all sat down to
eat dinner
no
okay so you testified at some point
late in the meal amber went upstairs to
look for johnny and stayed up there for
a long time correct
yes
and did mr deb sit down to dinner with
all of you
i don't know if we all actually sat down
at one point
did you see mr duff at some point leave
the dinner
i don't remember him leaving i remember
noticing that he was gone
did you see where mr death left
to where he went
i
either upstairs or out the front door
i didn't see it happen so i don't know
did you observe miss heard consume any
alcohol before she went to look for mr
depp
yes
what was she drinking
red wine
did she think drunk when she went to
look for mr duff
no
did you observe any injuries to ms heard
when she returned
no
did you deserve any injuries to mr desk
when he returned
no
do you remember that when mr depp and ms
heard
came downstairs
they were wearing different clothes
i don't remember
johnny changing clothes
i do remember that amber changed clothes
i remember anyone that was still there
when mr duff and miss heard came back
downstairs
i believe josh and myself
uh
david heard
and i i don't remember anyone else
specifically who was still there
you also testified that when quote you
went to look and found that a full
bottle of wine had hit and broken a
piece of art that amber really loved
above the bed and that broken glass was
scattered all over the bed
did i testify that
yeah
yes
is that an accurate description of what
you saw
yes
and where did you see this in what room
in their bedroom of ph3
how did you get to this penthouse from
penthouse five
i went
upstairs in pentax penthouse five
across
the top story which all three
penthouses were connected
through
to penthouse three
the bedroom was also on the top story
and all the way
through and around
you recall seeing any spilled wine
i think there was wine
um
yeah i think there was also spilled wine
on the bed and on the ground
you remember whether that bottle of wine
was broken or not
uh
i don't remember that the bottle was
broken but there's also
plenty of glasses around with wine in
them that
could have been part of that there was
glass everywhere
so you specifically remember glass being
everywhere upstairs is that fair
on the bed mostly
what kind of wine bottle was it
magnum
red do you remember
it would have been red
was it a magnum bottle
i don't think so
what picture have been damaged
i think it was one of um
elenorfini
what did it look like
i don't remember which one
you saw the aftermath
the aftermath fair
so you don't know that mr depp actually
threw the bottle
right
i don't know
michael could have put on the bottle
true
i'm sorry i didn't catch that
she said she could have have
she could have
and was the evening still happening
after you returned from observing the
bedroom
yes
do you recall any other issues happening
any further problems
during the evening
i don't recall any
no
you remember providing deposition
testimony about this thanksgiving
incident when you were deposed in the
divorce proceeding
if you have a transcript of uh that
original deposition i could take a look
at it and
and recall
do you have any independent recollection
of testifying during the divorce
proceeding about thanksgiving
i
are you talking about the deposition or
or testifying
i'm talking about your deposition
during the divorce to speaking
i remember the depo but i it was a very
long depo
and a lot of topics were covered
so
do you remember during teppo testifying
that mr depp and ms heard returned to
dinner
mr depp was quote acting like nothing
had happened do you remember that
testimony
i don't remember
the specifics of the testimony
okay
so can
a
videographer would you mind or attack uh
pulling up miss clinton's july 14 2016
deposition transcript
uh july 14 2016 is
volume 2.
where am i
um looking in the document
yes if you could please scroll down to
page 238
ms pennington if you could look on page
238 of your deposition transcript from
july 14 2016 line 23 and if you could
read to yourself through lot page 240
line 18.
do you have control
um
yeah um sorry it's just
i don't have like the scrolly things
uh what am i what line am i reading down
to
page 240 line 18.
foreign
okay
so you testified at your deposition that
after mr death and ms heard returned to
dinner mr dev was quote acting like
nothing happened do you remember that
um
yeah the the night has faded in my
memory but
as i read this yeah
is that an accurate description of what
you observed mr death
that evening
this description
yes
what are your observation the evening of
thanksgiving
that you couldn't tell whether mr depp
was drunk or angry that he just put on a
facade
um
i i couldn't tell what he was feeling i
didn't know what was going on
and you couldn't tell if he was drunk
correct
i couldn't tell
and you couldn't tell if he was angry
that evening either
well i can't
say what anybody else's emotions are at
any time
you didn't perceive him being angry
in front of you that evening
at me no
at anyone
not that i recall
so fair to say that mr death not being
angry to you when he came downstairs
after thanksgiving dinner right
he didn't
seem any particular way to me
do you testify that in december of 2015
amber called you over to her apartment
so that you could check her out
is that
a correct
statement
do you testify to that
yes
okay my question was after you arrived
you observed injuries to misheard right
yes
do you remember seeing that her head was
blood
was bloody where a chunk of hair had
been ripped out of the back of her head
yeah yes
was her head actively bleeding when you
saw her
um
it was um
it wasn't like dripping down her
her head but it was raw and red
was it actively bleeding if you remember
define actively bleeding
was there blood
yes
how could you tell hair had been ripped
out of her head
there was a bloody patch with hair
missing
where was her face red
her whole face
could the redness have been from crying
it could have been
where did her nose appear to be swollen
um
it would be like the
upper bridge
did you observe that ms hurd had any
black eyes
um
note that i recall
was there blood on her lips when you saw
her it was cut open
was there blood
coming out of that cut
sorry
um
i i don't remember there was blood
coming out of it at that point
wasn't on the top or bottom lip
what's on the bottom
before we go there have any independent
recollection of being a laceration on
this herd's forehead
there were many times that i saw
injuries on her if you would like to
show me a photo or
point me to another place where i can
remember
which injury
was in which instance then i can answer
the question
so you testified that ms heard had a
laceration on her forehead when you saw
her correct
yes
if you remember where on her forehead
was this laceration
[Music]
by the hairline
was it on the right or left side
i don't remember
was the laceration bleeding
um
i don't think so
sitting here today did you observe any
other injuries to ms heard that evening
that you
remember no
if we can go back to miss pennington's
witness statement in the united kingdom
that would be great
so in paragraph 20 ms pennington you
testified that after you saw mister you
quote called for assistance from a
private nurse who was part of the
concierge medical service which johnny
and amber used is that correct
yes
is aaron buran the private nurse you're
referring to here
um
yes
do you know approximately at what time
you called miss baran
um
evening
do you recall miss haram coming over to
the penthouses that night as well
i don't know if she came over that night
do you recall miss veron providing any
advice or recommendation to you on the
phone
um
i think she said to uh maybe not let her
go to sleep
and to
listen to her speech
keep an eye on her
and you did that
yes
you testified in paragraph 20 that on
december 15 2015 you took pictures with
ms hurd's injuries on your phone is that
correct
yes
did you change your photograph
i don't know if it was on my phone or
her phone
you see the third line down you say with
my phone
oh then it was my phone
did you alter the photographs in any way
miss pennington
no
do you recall sending the photographs to
anyone
no
do you recognize this photograph
yes
amber's face
with
swelling on her nose
bruising underneath her eyes
and to confirm you don't recognize
whether you took the photograph or not
right
i i don't know if i took that one
okay i'm gonna show you a document that
will be marked pennington exhibit three
do you recognize this photograph
yes
you recognize this photograph
yeah
yes
let's pull up pennington exhibit six
do you recognize this photograph
yes
did you take this photograph
yes
what is this photograph depicting
the
part of her scalp where the hair was
ripped out
you've testified previously that you
photographed a big clump of hair on the
floor which was blonde in color and
clearly belonged to amber do you
remember testifying to that
yes i remember
where did you see this clump of hair
it was um in ph 4 in the bedroom
and and just to confirm ph4 is this
where miss heard
used that penthouse as a closet
no
which pen tiles did miss heard use of
the closet
penthouse five
how did you know that the hair clearly
belonged to amber
hair had been
ripped out of her scalp and
it was her color on the floor of
her
apartment
but you didn't see the hair get ripped
out of her head right
correct
so you're understanding that this was
misheard's hair that was ripped out of
her head it was based on what miss heard
told you right
my understanding that it was miss
heard's hair was what i saw
on her body and on the floor
and the fact that it had been quote
ripped out of her head that was based on
what mr told you right
yes and common sense if we could pull up
pennington exhibit seven please
mrs pennington do you recognize this
photograph
yes
just a picture
of a clump of hair on the floor that you
referenced in your prior testimony
yes
just a picture
of a clump of hair on the floor that you
referenced in your prior testimony
objection vague
yes
did you take the photograph
yes
did you take it on your phone
yes
and before you took this photograph did
you move the hair in any way
no
okay so this picture is the clump of
hair exactly as you found it right
correct
and when did you take the photograph
when i was taking the other photographs
you didn't alter this photo in any way
correct
i did not alter this photo
you recall
taking a photograph of a wooden platform
bed which had a partially broken bed
frame
uh i do
and did you photograph the bed just as
you found it
yes
you didn't move anything off or onto the
bed
no
where was the
bed broken if you remember
it was a platform bed
and
the
edge of the platform
had like a
long shard of wood
off the corner or like off the edge
where was the broken bed in which
penthouse
four
in which room
the bedroom
i'm going to show you a document that
will be marked pennington exhibit eight
bear the base number pennington five
do you recognize this photograph ms
pennington
yes
did you take this photograph
yes
you see that on the left side of
what i assume is the the mattress and
the comforter um there appears to be
something on the bed
is it possible to zoom in
sure
you see in the picture there appears to
be something on the bed
yes
this is something that was already there
when you found the bed
i
don't
remember seeing that before
it's not something that you put on the
bed right
no
and you don't know what that is
no
so i believe you already testified that
the next game has heard was going on the
james corbin show right
which testify
which testification
today oh today
the next day yes
you were with miss heard when she was
getting ready for the show at her
apartment true
true
and was this in penthouse three
hmm
uh five
do you remember that uh
samantha melanie and a deer were there
assisting with her getting ready
yes
what's amanda
samantha uh
is johnny's
stylist and was also doing styling for
amber
and who is melanie
uh amber's makeup artist
and who is a deer
her amber's hair stylist
do you call anybody else being there
no
did you hear miss heard tell anyone of
these people about her injury
i remember her showing the injuries
what did she
show the injuries to
she showed
melanie her lip
and a deer the uh
missing hair on her head
but penny china i want to talk to you
about miss herd's birthday in april
2016.
um
you remember that after mitch ford's
birthday
dinner
you and ms hurd and some other friends
were scheduled to leave for coachella
the day after
yes
after the dinner
i know you attended the dinner but after
the dinner the next day when you arrive
to the penthouse
you notice shattered glass on the
turkey's bedroom floor
correct
what kind of blast was it
i don't know
can you tell where it comes from
i couldn't tell where it had come from
did you notice any other damage in the
bedroom
blazer is a broken lamp
the turd had two dogs at the time
correct
at the time of this
yeah
yes you recall where the dogs were when
you were in the bedroom with matured on
april 22nd 2016.
uh
in in the bed
were you concerned about the dogs
injuring themselves on the glass
yes
did she look upset
when i arrived
yeah
she was asleep
when she woke up
does she look upset to
you yes
what made you think that she was upset
or looked upset
she started crying
now let's turn to the events of may 21
2016.
okay at some point did miss her tell you
that mr death wanted to come to the
penthouse to get some stuff
on may 21 2016.
i don't remember what exact date
she said that but she said that
i'll make the representation to you that
we're talking about may 21st 2016 when
was heard alleged that mr depp threw a
phone at her so um
do you recall
knowing that mr duff was planning to
come by
the eastern columbia building
on or about may 21 2016 to collect some
stuff
i remember that she told me that he
wanted to come over
do you remember who was at the penthouse
before mr death
came over
on which
when
on may 21st 2016. you were there
obviously correct
uh
yes and ms heard was there
yes
what josh drew there
yes
was elizabeth mars there
yes
were you all
were you preparing for a jewelry show
the next day that you were doing
miss pennington
um
was preparing
was anybody assisting you prepare for
that show
um
yes and you were in penthouse five
on may 21 2016 preparing for that show
we were in and out of
um
penthouse five and penthouse one
at some point ms heard
left
penthouse one and penthouse five
and she went to penthouse three correct
at some point that evening
yes
sometime after mature left to go back to
penthouse 3 you received a text message
from her correct
uh yes
do you remember where you were when you
received this message
uh ph one pen has one
where was mr drew
with me in ph one
and where was miss
mars
she was either with us in ph 1 or
in ph 5.
and do you remember what you were doing
when you received this message
no
what did you do after you received this
message from miss heard
i
went straight over to ph3
could you remember when you went
straight over to page three mr duff must
heard yelling
uh sorry will you repeat the just the
beginning of the question you broke up a
bit
when you went to penthouse three did you
hear mr duff and mr yelling
yes
do you recall what they were saying to
each other
no
do you recall the door being locked to
penthouse 3 when you got there
the door was always locked
did you have a key
yes
did you use the key to open the door
yes
i believe you previously testified that
the penthouses three four and five were
all connected is that correct
correct
and so you can get from penthouse 5 to
penthouse 3 without going out the main
hallway is that right
correct
you entered penthouse three only mr duff
and mr bird were in the penthouse right
yes
do you know where mr duff was standing
yes
where wendy
in the
living room
what part of the living room
sort of like the entry like the in
between from the kitchen to the living
room
and where was the turd
on the other side of the living room
was she by the couch
yes
and were they approximately
how far apart
eight feet
ten feet
and they were both standing when you
first came in
yes
what's the first thing you remember miss
pennington when you entered the
penthouse
the first thing i remember was
just hearing
them i don't remember what they were
saying but it was verbal argument
and
then he continued to yell and
i i
went over to her and then stepped
between him
where was mr death when you sat between
them
he
the
sofa is an l in the corner of the living
room the coffee table uh fit into the
l shape
uh amber was on the far side johnny was
on the other side of the l
with the coffee table between them
at some point mr deaf security team came
in is that correct
correct
and that was jerry judge and sean beth
yes
where was mr duck standing when they
entered the apartment
in the space between
the
living room and the kitchen
and you were with me turned on the sofa
yes
mr duff eventually left
penthouse 3 with his vic is that correct
eventually yes
and he left you and mr burden penthouse
3.
yes
from the moment you entered house three
until mr death left did you see mr def
touch misheard
i didn't see him touch her
did you see him throw anything at her
i didn't see him throw anything at her
what did you do after mr death left
house penthouse 3.
we took amber to
penthouse one
is that where mr drew and miss mars work
i don't know where they were
specifically
i don't know if they were in different
places or which apartment they were in
what did you do once you and matured got
back to penthouse fun
she wanted her purse
so um
i asked josh to go find her purse
in ph3
did you observe any property damage in
any of the penthouses
yes
what damage did you observe in penthouse
3
uh
he had
smashed a bunch of the
on his way out i saw this on his way out
he had knocked over a bunch of uh
items that were on the kitchen island
fruit baskets and bottles and
things like that
that was the main damage in ph3
what damage did you see in ph5
in ph 5
there
were photos that had been smashed off
the wall
items that i had been working on
on the table that had been thrown
against the wall
um
yeah
you've um also observed injuries to
mature space correct
yes
what did you see
uh her cheek was
red and swelling
do you recall when you noticed
her cheek
no
but you didn't see how this occurred
right
i didn't see
at some point two police officers
arrived is that correct
at two points two police officers
arrived
before the first set of police officers
showed up have you cleaned up any of the
damage in penthouse 3 or 5.
i don't remember
where were you when the police officers
arrived the first set
ph3
um
did you see mr speak to the officer
the first step
yes
did you see the officers enter penthouse
3
yes
they look around penthouse 3.
yes
should they enter
house five the first set of police
officers
i'm not sure
is it your testimony ms pennington that
they
the first set of police officers saw the
damage you alleged mr defcon
i don't know
what they
saw but there was damage there
and another set of two officers came
later in that night is that correct
between the first set of officers
leaving and the second set of officers
arriving how much time had passed
i don't remember exactly
you have an approximation from how much
time had passed an hour to
last night
less than three
three hours less than three hours
less than three
in this time do you recall cleaning up
any of the damage to penthouse three or
five
i don't recall
do you recall mr speaker either of the
second set of officers
um no i don't remember
she did or not
did these officers the second step look
around penthouse 3.
i can't guess so i don't know
miss pennington
have you ever personally witnessed mr
depp's physically attack misheard
yeah can you be specific to physically
attacked
did you ever witness mr
brightness heard
no
did you ever witness mr deb throw
anything at ms heard
i never witnessed him throw anything
at her around her you guess
the question is
did you ever witness mr depp throw
anything at ms hurd
no
did you ever witness miss pick miss hurt
no
did you ever see mr depp
physically injure mr cause for an injury
i didn't see it
so that's a no right
i didn't
your honor at this point um i start
asking miss pennington some questions so
we'll play that but may we just approach
to just get straight on some exhibits
okay
thank you ronnie
are we ready yes yes sorry
now i understand that you've
testified a number of times about um
some of the events that we touched on
yesterday right
uh yes
has there ever been anything
in any of those prior sworn statements
or testimony that you've given that has
prevented you from telling the truth
and
is all of your prior
sworn testimony including the testimony
you gave yesterday true and accurate to
the best of your knowledge
yes
are you here today on behalf of
one side or the other and by that i mean
on behalf of amber or on behalf of
johnny
no
are you are you would you consider
yourself
adverse
or hostile to either party
no
any other time that you can remember
not specifically no
was there a name
for
what you described as
mr depp's different self
yes
what was that name we called it the
monster it was we
all of us me johnny
amber and anyone else in the
inner circle that was privy to
the private things that would happen
how do you know that johnny called it
the monster
he named it that
you heard him refer to this other
version of himself as the monster
directly
either heard or uh
saw it written in a text
do you receive texts from
mr death um
referring to this other version of
himself as the monster
i can't remember specifically
any of them
but you do recall hearing or reading mr
depp directly referring to himself as
the monster
yes
and why did you do that
she asked for my help
and over the course of your relationship
when
um
when amber needed your help you tried to
be there for her right
yes what do you mean by scary
i was scared for amber
i was sad for her and i was so sad for
johnny
she is my friend too
and i really wanted them to be able to
get it together
why were you scared for amber
you could be very unpredictable
and she um
didn't have a lot of self-preservation
what specifically
um
what type of harm were you worried about
for amber
in the beginning
i wasn't worried
towards the end
when the um
physical abuse was more evident
i was worried
i was worried for her physical safety i
was worried that when he turned
he might accidentally do something that
was worse than he ever intended
when you say
talk about
[Music]
abuse is this
signs of abuse that you personally
observed
can you explain
what you mean specifically by that
did you observe
physical effects
on amber
of that abuse
yes
um
you testified a little bit yesterday
about um
an incident between johnny and amber
that took place in hicksville you
remember that
yes
tell
tell me as best you can everything that
you remember about that
we were sitting around the campfire
i don't remember who the larger group
was
and
amber and kelly sue were sitting on a
chair
together hugging
and
johnny came up and
said get your hands off my woman
and it was surprising because
it was a very benign
two friends sitting on the same chair
hanging out
and
it was also surprising because
johnny had been hanging out with
everybody
um in a friendly way and
a switch flipped
when that happened
and um
[Music]
amber got up
went to go come for johnny
and then um and then they went back to
their trailer
how would you describe johnny's tone
when he said get off my woman
at first i thought it was a joke
i thought he was kidding because it was
so unexpected from the
way that the rest of the night had been
going
and um
and then at some point
uh i think amber realized that it was
not a joke and got up to
diffuse the situation
did you perceive kelly sue to be acting
inappropriately in any way toward
misheard
no
it is had you seen
um when you said a switch flipped in mr
death that's that was your testimony
right
just now yeah just now
yes
was it surprising to you to see
no
and why not
he switched
sometimes
and
what do you mean by that when you say he
switched
johnny would be acting
like his wonderful
self for a certain portion of
occasion where people were hanging out
or
um sometimes just privately at home and
i never knew what caused it um
switch would happen to where
he would either
disappear or go somewhere off by himself
or
his mood would change to something
darker
and
what do you recall
um and we'll get to
to to specific instances in a little bit
but when you say his mood would change
to something darker do you remember any
specific examples of
of of times that you witnessed when his
mood changed to something darker
i can't remember um
at this moment specific times
when it would happen
generally
he would go
away from where the rest of the people
were
amber would
follow to comfort
sometimes they wouldn't come back
sometimes they would
in um tell us about the next morning at
hicksville
what you saw
and observed
i went to
the trailer to go knock on the door
um
i think they had already left though
i went in
and saw the
[Music]
disarray
describe the disarray as best you can
um
like i said yesterday the light fixtures
had been knocked off
things were strewn about the trailer
cushions off the
couch bank
over the course of you now you've known
miss heard since 2003 right
yes have you ever known her to
not like pick light fixtures off a wall
no
have you ever known her to throw pillows
and cushions off couches
no
have you ever known her to
get in a rage and destroy property
no
have you ever known her to threaten
someone's life
no
what did amber tell you um well
did you ever have a conversation with
miss heard about
what happened in that trailer in
hicksville yes
i'd like to
fast forward a little bit in time uh
miss pennington to
um
and
an episode that we talked about
yesterday um to to some extent um
do you remember um
being with amber after something that
happened uh the day before she went on
the james corden show
in december 2015
yes
what do you
remember
um and i know this is
painful and emotional but give me your
best recollection of
what you recall um from that time period
from the night before
you were
were you with amber the night before the
james corden appearance
yes
and were you with her the day of the
james corden appearance
yes
and did you observe um
miss heard and miss herg's residence
the day before the james corden
appearance and the day of the james
corden appearance
yes
so with that um
tell me everything that you can remember
starting with the day before
and i may interrupt you and ask you to
to clarify certain things but
that's everything to remember
she asked me to come over to
her residence
ph3 or
ph5 i don't remember which one i entered
and
she was very upset
her face was red
swollen
the hair had um
been ripped out of her head
i went through
all of the
penthouses she didn't cancel
i don't think i even slept that night
watching her just to make sure she
is that because you were worried she had
a concussion
yes
why did you tell her that you were gonna
go take pictures throughout the
penthouses
why wouldn't i
miss pennington i'm gonna um
you saw
a few selected pictures yesterday i'm
gonna um i'm gonna show you a number of
pictures
um
today uh
that that we need to to go through and
um
and i'll ask you some questions about
them okay
are you able to see exhibit 15.
yeah i can see it can you miss
pennington
yes
pennington does this um does this
picture
truly inaccurately depict um
miss herd's appearance
on december
december 2015 um
during the night that you just discussed
yes
[Music]
do you know whether or not you took this
picture
we do not
that you were with miss heard that
evening
after the incident
it was
what room was this taken in
this is the bathroom
of
johnny and amber's bedroom in ph 3.
what um what injuries if any do you
observe on this herd in this picture
her
right eye has a mark and a bruise
her nose is swollen
there's bruising on her left eye as well
and exhibit 16 that's up
what is this picture uh miss pennington
there's a picture of amber's face
with bruising and a mark on her right
eye
swelling on her nose
bruising on the left eye
in the same bathroom
and when was this picture taken
i assume the same night
is that the night in december
2015 that you've been testifying about
for the last few minutes
yeah
do you do you see um
behind
um
behind miss heard's left ear there's a
picture on the wall and then a
writing a note above the picture
yes
what is um
what is that note signed
you can tell
steve
to your understanding who is steve
johnny
and what does it say right above
um
that says you're steve
what's the line above that say
eternally
from all
something always up three exclamation
points
love you eternally your steve
and
steve
in that note
refers to the same man that
you understood to have inflicted these
injuries on misheard correct
yes
does this picture truly and accurately
reflect um
what you observed on misheard in that
night in december 2015.
partially
when you said partially um
what do you mean by
that you can't see the rest of the
injuries
what other injuries are you referring to
the
hair
being pulled out
exhibit 17 is up
what is this a picture of miss
pennington
amber's face
turned at a slight profile
with a bruise on her eye
swelling on her nose
and um
when was this picture taken
appears to be the same
night
a moment of the previous two pictures
does this picture fairly inaccurately
depict um
at least in part miss heard's appearance
uh on that night
yeah
exhibit 18 is up
what is this document mrs pennington
of amber's face
with two black eyes
and swollen bottom lip
did you take this photo
i don't remember
you said a swollen nose
yes
does this picture fairly and accurately
depict um
at least in part miss herd's appearance
on that night in december 15 2015.
yes did you take pictures of miss heard
that night
yes
you believe that you took this picture
i don't know
but in any event it accurately reflects
what misheard this earth's appearance
from that evening
yes
exhibit 19 is up
and i'm sorry this is so hard miss
pennington
we just need to get through as
best
what is this picture
this is amber's face
turn to profile
um showing more of her bottom bloody lip
and her right bruised eye
and
what night does this or when
does this
show amber
it appears to be the same night and the
same series of photos
as before
where was this picture taken if you know
oh
it's in the bedroom
facing the
she's sitting on the bed and it's facing
the
windows
was anyone
with
you and amber
that night after you came over
i i don't think so no
so
is it fair to assume that either you or
amber took this picture
yes
does it look like ms heard took this
picture
no
do you recall taking this picture
i i took a lot of pictures
it would be
yes
does miss herd's lower lip look like
it's just chapped
no it does not
does it look like she just has a cold
sore
it does not look like a cold sore the
bit 20 is up
what is this a picture of miss
pennington
this is a picture of the
of amber's hairline
a scratch
injury on the hairline
and my thumb
holding the hair back so that you can
see it
is this does this
picture depict
marks that you saw on amber
on the night in december 2015
that we've been discussing
uh
or the next morning
one or the other
yes
and
um
lucas if you could just go back really
quickly to the last picture
please uh pennington 19.
i may have asked you this miss
pennington but i just want to make clear
for the record does this um picture
fairly inaccurately
depict
mrs hurt's appearance on
that night in december 15 2015 that
we've been discussing
yes
because 21 is up
what is this a picture of
it's pennington
this is a close-up picture
of the side of amber's nose and
mouth
go ahead go ahead
she has a
swelling and an injury on her bottom lip
are there any other injuries
you observe
in this picture
and see
you could see at the top of the photo um
bruising on her eye and the small mark
underneath her
underneath her bottom eyelid
did miss her uh
did she typically have that small mark
underneath her eye or bruising around
her eyes
she did not
usually have that small mark
we're bruising underneath her eyes
did she typically have injuries to her
lip
sometimes
and over the course of your
friendship with miss heard
during the time that she was in a
relationship with mr depp how often
would you all communicate
sorry can you repeat that question
during the time that miss heard was in a
relationship with mr death
how often would you communicate with ms
hurd like every day
[Music]
when she was filming less
when she was home
all the time
and you just testified i believe it
wasn't the only incident which you
observed
injuries to miss herd's face or lips
correct
correct
were there any other times that you
observed injuries to miss serge's face
or lips
yes
exhibit 22 visit
what is this a picture of a spennington
picture is uh hair pulled back to show
the abrasion on the scalp where hair has
been removed
whose head is that
that's amber's head
was this do you know when this picture
was taken
either the night of the event or
the next day
and by event you're referring to the
event in december of 2015 that we've
been talking about
yes
do you recall taking this picture miss
pennington of miss heard scout
yes
does this
picture fairly inaccurately depict the
top of misheard's scalp
um
during the day of or at the day after
the december 2015 incident that you've
been giving testimony about
yes
exhibit 23 isn't
what is this a picture of miss
pennington there's a picture of a clump
of amber's hair
on the black carpet of the bedroom
uh ph4
with my finger
there to
show the scale of the hair
did you take this picture
yes
when did you take this picture
the
night of the event
the night of the event the
december the occurrence that we've been
talking about
in december 2015
and um how did you know that was amber's
hair
hair had been ripped out of her head
this is the color of her hair it's her
home
and this you said was in the bedroom of
penthouse five
four
have you ever known miss heard to to
pull out clumps of her own hair
misheard ever
paint on
bruises or use makeup
to make it appear as if she had a bruise
when in fact she didn't
to your heart
no the opposite
what do you mean when you say the
opposite
she often had to cover bruises and
injuries on her face with makeup
did you
see her cover bruises on her face with
makeup
yes
can we pull up um the document titled
december 2015 alh 28 underscore b please
what is this picture miss pennington
is a picture of amber
she has
underneath her
right eye
she's her coat and her shirt on they're
in the kitchen
she's in the kitchen
a ph3
do you know
when or approximately when this picture
was taken
um
the day following the december
event or the day after maybe
i don't know exactly when
and
did you take this picture
i don't
know
does it fairly inaccurately depict
amber's appearance
um
on the day you described
on one of the days following yes
exhibit
do you know what this is a picture of ms
pennington
this is a picture of um
the nightstand on the right side of the
bed in johnny and amber's bedroom
in ph
3. it has a
lamp that's fallen down
a
book of rolling papers half a lemon
a plastic coffee mug of infinidum the
hill which is johnny's production
company
a bottle of tums
a bottle of
tea
broken glass
and a small blue book
on the floor that i can't make out what
that is
did you ever know amber to
break glass
next to our bed
no
what's your knowledge about
mr depp's
tendency to
break things made of glass my knowledge
is that
i
saw him do it once and then i saw
the aftermath of
him breaking glass many times
and on that evening in december 2015 did
you see um
that that we've been discussing did you
see broken glass
around
the residence
yes
let's go to the next picture december
2015 alh
underscore 509 underscore b
you've seen this picture before what's
this a picture of miss pennington
this is a picture of the platform bed
and the bedroom of penthouse four
the edge of the platform bed has a shard
of wood that has broken off onto the
floor did you take this picture
yes
when did you take it
um
[Music]
either the night of the event or the
next day
and when you say event are you referring
to what are you referring to
the december 15th
event that we've been speaking about
you said december 15th you mean december
2015
uh yes sorry 2015.
where is this bed in the residence
this is in the
penthouse four it's the middle
uh house between the
main residence ph3
amber's closet ph5 this is the uh one of
the rooms that you walk through to get
to
to go through
the upper story of the homes
have you ever known miss heard to
destroy a bed frame
no
have you ever known go ahead sorry
uh no
have you ever known this hurt to destroy
furniture generally
no
miss pennington um
in in all the photos that you
um
have taken
of
evidence or incidents or the aftermath
of incidents
between amber and johnny
have you ever done anything to
alter those photos or
you know make them appear to depict
something that wasn't actually there
wasn't actually real
no
i want to talk about the day of the late
late show um when i say that do you
understand i'm referring to
amber's appearance on the james corden
show
yes
the late late show with james corden
um
were you um were you with amber
when she
um when she got ready for her appearance
on that show
yes
who else was present
um
a deer
that uh who's her hair stylist
melanie her makeup artist and samantha
her stylist
did um
were you there when her hair and makeup
was being styled or put on before her
appearance on james corden
yes
did you see anyone
paint on
a wound on her lip
or put makeup on her face to make it
appear that there was a wound on her lip
did you observe um
anyone
ripping clumps of her hair out of her
head
no
miss pennington did you um
did you
um
to the extent that it's alleged that
miss heard had no injuries when she went
on the james corden show
what is your reaction to that
my reaction is that that is a false
assessment or statement
and what's the basis for that testimony
because i saw injuries
on her body
from the
time
directly after they happened
throughout the next night the next day
and as they continued to heal
in the in the time that you spent um
with johnny did he ever express a
similar sentiment that he was threw up
or [ __ ] up
in his words
yes
and what did you um tell me what you can
remember about the instances when he
said that and what your understanding
was of what he meant
my
understanding was that he
was sorry and apologetic
and
for what
for his behavior
when you say behavior what what are you
referring to
verbal arguments
physical arguments
and
that was what he made clear to you in in
in
things that he said to you
sorry
what he made clear to me in
our conversations was that
he was very sorry and that he
was working to
get clean and get better
and that he was asking for
forgiveness and trying to
think that he was going to get better
did you ever see him get better
when
a lot of times
but did you ever see him get better
permanently
no
your honor
at this point we start questioning miss
pennington about may 21st we're happy to
keep going but if you wanted to take a
break i think we're about halfway
through this volume okay let's go and
take our morning recess for 15 minutes
again do not discuss the case with
anybody and don't do any outside
research okay
shhh
all right let's just come back at 11
o'clock then okay thank you
the jury
okay
so
you
all right it can be seated
with your witness yes we'll resume with
the testimony of rockell pennington all
right thank you
i want to talk about
the events of
may 21st 2016.
um do you remember that night miss
pennington
yes
walk us through um
what you recall about the evening of may
21st 2016.
so
in ph 5
i was
getting things ready for a
artist craft show
that i had and um
making jewelry
and
my friend liz was there josh was there
amber was helping
we were set up in the downstairs
living room of ph five
and
liz mars yes okay and and your fiance
joshua drew is that right
yes
and at some point amber got a message
from johnny that said that he wanted to
come over and
talk or pick something up i don't
remember what the exact message was and
i always thought it was a really bad
idea but
can't stop somebody from coming over to
their own home
and so
amber went
upstairs to
get ready for him to come over
and
eventually he
showed up
i didn't see him show up i didn't hear
him show up
he went to ph 3
and
and then at some point i got a text from
her
i might have checked in
or i got a text from her that said
come over
so i tried to come over there and the
door was locked their front door was
locked so i went to go get my key
i have a master key to i had a master
key to all of the apartments
and i came back
unlocked the door
and
he was yelling and i don't remember
exactly what he was saying
and
she was just she was calling for help
and that had never happened before
saying help help me
i went and i
uh cut through the
space between the coffee table and the
sofa
and i went up to him
and he was yelling and yelling and i
just i put my hands up on his chest and
i was like stop
just stop just trying to calm him down
um
and he he hit my hands away
and
so i just went straight over to amber
she sat down on the couch she was crying
and
i just put my body over her
and he came
a little bit closer to us and
uh
he was yelling at her to like get up or
i don't know quit crying or get up or
something and it was really loud and he
was getting closer and closer
and i remember think there was this um
like big orange
um
ceramic ash tray on the
coffee table
and i was thinking
if he gets any closer i'm just going to
pick up that ashtray and like hit him
with it because he was
so close over us and um
and then at that point
jerry and sean came in
from the front door
of ph3 and came in and they you know
they were like boss boss you know come
on let's get out of here and um
jerry always called him boss he's like
boss come on come on boss let's go let's
go
and
then johnny grabbed like his bat his
leather bag off the stool that was by
the island and he had a big
magnum bottle of wine and he was just
like smashing stuff off the island and
yelling i don't remember exactly what he
was saying and then
they finally
they finally left and i could hear out
in the hall just like banging and
smashing and clattering around i was
just holding amber
sort of just waiting for the
waiting for it to pass and
clear um
until a little bit later and then i
think
josh came in
why did you get between and and put your
hands on mr depp and get between him and
and miss heard
i just thought i could calm him down
and
when he hit your hands away and then you
went and laid on her
why did you do that
this is the thing to do
how would you describe mr depp's um
mood
irate
were you afraid that mr depp was going
to hurt miss heard
yes
and
when he stood over you um
you testified a little bit too but
describe what he was yelling
as he stood over the couch i don't
remember everything that he said the
thing that sticks out the most is that
he was
just yelling at her to get up
to get the [ __ ] up
did you let her
no
and
where were you just to be clear where
were you when you
received the message from amber asking
you to come over to penthouse three
in either p
five ph five or ph one
you weren't already in penthouse 3 when
you got that text
no
to the extent that there are allegations
that you were lying in wait in penthouse
three
before johnny walked into that penthouse
how do you respond to those
that is not true
i will also represent to you miss
pennington that
mr depp's lawyer
has
been quoted as saying quote amber heard
and her friend rocky pennington staged
the may 21 crime scene to prove the
abuse allegation against johnny depp
is that statement true
no
did you stage anything
about may 21st 2016.
no
did
amber stage anything
to your knowledge about may 21st 2016 no
describe for us the damage that you
observed mr depp
cause
to the penthouses
to penthouse three
uh
in three
stuff had been knocked off the kitchen
counter
stuff had been knocked off a
the bar cart
by him um
by johnny i saw this happen on his way
out
he
with what
with a wine bottle what other damage
can you remember mr deb causing
in the hallway
there was wine spilled wine splash
spilled in the hallway
there was a dent
on the outside of uh ph one's door front
door
and then in
ph five where we had been
getting stuff ready for my craft fair
uh
my
jewelry and and
materials had been thrown against the
wall and everything that was on the
table was
like
strewn off of the table thrown down
i'd like to go through
uh with you some some photographs um
of the incident um that we talked about
so can you pull up may 21st 2016 alh
7051 please
and and while he's pulling that up ms
pennington um did you
or
either yourself or anyone else take
photographs of the in the aftermath of
this incident
yes
who took photographs
josh drew
that's the only person that i can say
for sure
were you with mr drew when he was taking
photographs
um
i can't remember
did you
go through the penthouses to see where
the damage has been done
eventually
um miss pennington what what is this a
picture of if you know
this is a picture of the
living room in ph 5.
with
the the back corner of the sofa it has
the beads that i had been working on and
the stand that i used to display them
thrown
to the wall some of the beads are on the
windowsill
the stand is broken
and did you uh does this fairly and
accurately reflect damage that you saw
to
penthouse five
on may 21 2016.
yes
exhibit 30 is up
what is this a picture of if you know
this is a picture of the
johnny and amber's bed
bedroom bed in ph 3.
it has several photos
framed photos
stacked on it
and do those photos appear to be intact
these do yes
in your experience of those photos
normally sit on the bed
no
does this
did you witness
well was this part of the aftermath of
what mr depp did in penthouse 3.
i i didn't see him take these down but
they were not down
before he came over
does it fairly inaccurately depict
what you witnessed the night of may 21st
2016.
i didn't see this happen but i did see
this
scenario
you you
you saw the pictures that that's my
question is does this fairly
inaccurately depict something that you
personally saw
on may 21st 2016
yes
all right let's pull up 7053 please
so my question mr pennington will be
what is this a picture of
um
can i can the info thing move off to the
side you know no i don't not in not in
this version of the pictures um so i
apologize for that if you need it zoomed
in or out
it's the landing of one of the
staircases
and what do you see on the picture
it's broken glass uh and something
spilled on the landing of one of the
staircases i can't tell if it's uh p3 or
4p5
okay
does this picture fairly inaccurately
depict something that you observed on
the night of may 21st 2016
yes
did you nev ever know miss heard to
smash glasses on staircases
no
did you find that question vague and
ambiguous miss pennington
no
32 is up
is this a picture of miss pennington
these are stairs appearing of the same
staircase with broken glass on them
does this picture fairly inaccurately
depict um something that you personally
observe the night of may 21st 2016
yes
33 is up
what is this a picture of miss
pennington
this is a picture of
the
floor mat
in front of the doors that would lead
out to the balcony of ph3 and it has a
broken
looks like top of a martini glass on it
okay um
did you did you see um
this glass or
material around this being broken on the
evening may 21st 2016
yes
and who broke this glass
i did
and does this photo fairly and
accurately depict uh
something that you observed after mr
depp left penthouse 3 on may 21st 2016
yes
exhibit 34 is up
um what is this a picture of miss
bennington
this is the
space between the cabinets in the
refrigerator and the kitchen islands
uh it has a rug on it and it has a fruit
basket and fruit on the ground
and do you know who knocked that fruit
on the ground
yes
who
johnny
and does this fairly inaccurately depict
um
damage that you saw on may 21 2016
yes
exhibit 35 is up
thank you
what is this a picture of miss
pennington
this is the landing
of ph 5
that amber's office was set up on
and this is her desk and her files
and
boxes have been out turned and there's
papers all over the floor and
and is this how misheard normally kept
her office area
no
does this fairly inaccurately depict
damage that you observed on may 21st
2016
yes
36 is up
is this that same office area
yes and is this uh an accurate depiction
of what you observed on may 21 2016
yes
37 is up
what is this a picture of miss
pennington
this is a picture of
two photos on the column
the staircase
leading up to amber's office the top
photo is a group photo
uh
savannah whitney
io myself amber aaron
britney morgan
the
we were in london the
glass is smashed
the bottom photo is a photo of amber and
me
in france
is this photo fairly and accurately
depict damage that you observed on may
21st 2016.
yes
38 is up
what is this a picture of
a picture of a large bottle of wine on
the floor
on may 21st 2016.
yes
is this the bottle he was swinging
um
if you know
i don't know
but it accurately depicts
something you observed on may 21st 2016.
yes
did you did you um
did did you notice you or misheard or
anyone that you were with
spilling wine in penthouses that night
in order to stage damage
no
and and by what is this a picture of i
meant
the whole scene
oh
sorry
oh
um
it's a it's a picture on the floor
uh do you know what penthouse that is in
can you zoom out again please
three
um
do you uh
do you know who knocked this picture on
the floor
um
i didn't see it knocked down
did
um
other than mr depp did you see anyone
causing any damage or knocking anything
down in any of the penthouses on may
21st 2016
no
and did you see mr depp knocking things
down
yes
does this picture fairly and accurately
describe something that you observed on
may 21st 2016
yes
okay
um can you describe uh did you see any
injuries on amber
on may 21st 2016.
just a swollen like red swollen cheek
let's pull up uh the may 21st 2016 alh
7077 please
and while he's doing that um did you
i know we talked about pictures of
damage in the penthouses did you take
pictures of misheard that evening
hmm
i don't remember if it was me or josh
were you present when pictures were
taken of misheard on may 21st 2016
yes
does this picture
fairly and accurately reflect
observations you may have misheard on
may 21st 2016
yes
42 is up
what is this picture miss pennington
this is amber's face
it's red
the right
cheek and eye is
more red and swollen her right
left
does this
fairly inaccurately depict
this hurts condition that you observed
that evening
yes
can you pull up 7083 please what is this
picture of
this is amber's face turned at a slight
profile
her eye is red and bruised
the side
this the side brow
temple and cheekbone
does this fairly inaccurately depict
this herd's condition that you witnessed
on may 21st 2016
yes and were you present when police
arrived
yes
um
what were there two sets of police
officers
yes
and what penthouse did they come in
penthouse three both times
how close were you to the police officer
in the same room
okay
could you see damage that he had caused
while you were standing there when the
police officers were present
yes
did you ever hear miss heard
say
express any
financial motivations for wanting to
remain in this relationship with mr depp
no
did miss herd ever express that if she
went public against uh with what
happened on may 21 2016 that she stood
to gain financially from doing so
now
now
at some point after may 21st 2016 um
miss heard filed for divorce from mr
death right
correct
and at some point she filed for domestic
violence restraining order against him
is that right
yes
and i'm gonna i'm gonna come back to
that line of questions in a second but
before i forget
um
you mentioned jerry and sean bette on
the night of may 21st right
was there a space in the upper the floor
of the ecb where they would wait for mr
death when he was in one of the
penthouses
yes
and and what was that space
uh
we called it the guard shack and it was
a
vestibule
separate from
the penthouses except that a door from
the vestibule
uh also connected to the door of the
patio
of ph five
was the um
okay
was it if if someone were in the
vestibule
or the guard shack as you called it
would they have seen you go into
penthouse 3 when amber requested that
you do so
no
did you see
jerry or sean or any security guards
when you entered penthouse 3 that
evening
no
okay
um going back to uh the domestic
violence restraining order did you
accompany miss herd to court when she
got that
order
yes
i'd like you to pull up uh please may
2016 court pennington one two nine two
please
and while he's doing that um
do you know if miss heard wore any
makeup that morning
uh
i i don't remember seeing her put on any
makeup
was that rare for miss heard not to wear
makeup
yes
what is this a picture of
this is amber
and jody her publicist sitting
on the bench in the
hallway
waiting room of
the courthouse
when
um the day that the
uh
restraining order was filed
do you see any injuries on misheard
i do describe what you see
on her cheek
bone
right cheekbone is uh bruised
and how long after may 21st was this
approximately
um
i don't know i don't
remember matter of days
weeks
uh
less than a week
did you ever see any makeup artist paint
on this bruise
put a fake bruise on this hurts face
no
can you please pull up um
pennington
one two nine five please
and and before we actually before we do
does this picture fairly inaccurately
depict
miss herd's condition the morning she uh
or the day she applied for the domestic
violence restraining order
yes
do you know whether you took this shirt
to the best of my recollection i took
that
and i'm going to ask you the same thing
about this next picture one two nine
five
ask uh
to the best of my recollection i took
that
and does that fairly and accurately
depict miss heard's condition on that
morning
yes
46 is up
what is that a picture of
it is amber at a slight profile
in the same courthouse room
her hair is behind her ear you can see a
picture of a bruise on her cheekbone
she looks like a skeleton
did you take this picture
yes
based on your personal knowledge is
there any truth to the allegation that
amber did this because she's quote a
gold digger
no miss pennington um
you came to understand at some point um
well at some point did you learn that mr
def had had lost the tip of his finger
in australia
yes
and what is the that other way that you
learned that mr depp had cut the tip of
his finger off
he showed it to me
in addition to showing you how did you
learn from mr death that he had cut off
the tip of his own finger
he told me
what did he tell you
said um
i don't remember how he said he cut the
tip of his finger off but
while the nurse was dressing it i
wanted to see it i also had a very small
injury on the tip of my finger
uh and i i continued to
see it throughout its healing process
but i don't remember
how he told me
how he cut it off
but you remember that he told you that
he cut it off
yes
mrs pennington i'll finish
where we started which is
you've you've given a number of um
you've testified a number of times about
the events that we talked about today
and i really appreciate you
um
you being here today and talking about
these i know it was tough and it was
emotional at times um
if
is there anything that you would change
about any of the testimony that you've
given today or previously about any of
these events
no
and you've done your best every time
you've testified about this
to tell
the full truth
about everything that you know
everything that you saw everything that
you heard everything that you've
observed right
i have done the very best to tell
the absolute truth
exactly as i remember it
at all of the points of time
all right yes sir your next witness yes
your honor that concludes the testimony
raquel pennington um miss heard calls
joshua drew as her next witness okay um
and if we may approach just to discuss a
couple examples that's by deposition is
that correct it is by deposition
foreign
so
are we ready not quite okay
yes your honor okay the
this is uh misheard calls joshua drew
thank you thank you
what is your occupation i run my own
hospitality development consulting firm
are you also a chef not anymore what if
any education have you had since high
school
i have my associates uh of science in
culinary arts and from what institution
johnson and wales university did you
receive a degree from there i did
in what year uh that would have been
2003. who is raquel rose pennington my
ex-wife
because i want to be respectful how
should i refer to her miss pennington
rocky or raquel rocky or raquel is
perfectly fine
you were married to rocky so there came
a time when you began to date rocky
correct correct when did you start
dating rocky it would have been june of
2014 and did there come a time when you
became engaged to rocky correct when was
that that would have been
in
summer of
2015
yep i believe
do you recall when you were divorced
from rocky officially september 24th of
last year we separated officially
october of the previous year when did
you first meet amber heard
probably about three or four weeks after
raquel and i have started dating very
early on when did you first meet johnny
depp
shortly after i met amber i want to say
if memory serves about
five or six weeks after raquel and i
started dating again i understand it was
a long time ago but do you recall under
what circumstances you met him funny
enough i actually do very clearly
i had come over
under the auspice of what was called
family movie night and it was amber and
johnny and jack
i honestly don't remember whether lily
rose was there she might have come later
at a certain point
and it was just us in
their apartment eating burgers and
watching movies since that time on how
many occasions have you
seen and
interacted with johnny depp from that
very first time on movie night
i couldn't even speculate the number of
it's it's not that it was infrequent so
much as it was
sporadic and honestly for a large
portion of it fairly casual not the kind
of thing where you would just count the
number of times it was
regular interactions over various
periods of time well your council is not
going to let you speculate
but i'm going to ask you to get a range
is it more than 10 times yes
more than 50 times yes
from the time that you first met mr depp
on movie night until this very moment
sitting here today have you ever seen mr
depp strike amber heard no
have you ever seen him throw a telephone
at her no have you ever
uh seen him
hit her with a fist no
have you ever lived at a building
located at 849 south broadway in los
angeles known as the eastern columbia
building correct
did you live in the condo known as
penthouse one correct
with whom did you live in penthouse one
raquel pennington
from when to when did you live in
penthouse one with rocky pennington
um
again my memory is a little bit foggy of
exact dates
uh
yeah you'll have to bear with me a
minute here um
so while i was a frequent guest i didn't
actually live there until i want to say
about october or november of 2015.
was rocky already living in penthouse
one when you started visiting and
ultimately moved in there yes
did miss pennington move into penthouse
one in or about june of 2014.
i couldn't tell you with any specificity
but i believe it's around that time
frame who owned penthouse one at the
time johnny depp
while you and
rocky live together in penthouse one
did did you or she have a key that
allowed you access to
all of the penthouses on that floor
everything except ph2 yes
did
at the time did mr depp and ms
heard live together in ph3 sporadically
yes
the key that to which you and rocky had
access allowed either of you to
enter ph3 correct correct
did it who was in
ph 5 at the time nobody nobody lived in
ph 5 for the entirety of our time there
did you or rocky ever pay mr depp any
rent to live in ph1
offered and refused
did you consider the refusal of your
offer to be a generous gesture by mr
death exceedingly in your experiences mr
generally generous to his friends yes
is he generous to people generally yes
did mr depp own penthouse five yes
would your key have opened penthouse
side yes
when you and rocky were living here in
penthouse one
did you ever notice that there were
security personnel
standing outside
the door of penthouse 3 when mr depp
was in penthouse 3. not normally no
did you ever see the security personnel
standing outside of his door on very
rare occasion normally they were in a
storage room off to the side of ph 5.
moving aside from
mr bett and mr judge
why you stayed
at the east columbia building did you
come to know any of the employees of the
building
uh
casually
who is trinity esparza she was one of
the front desk people
did you have communications with her in
the course of living there yes did you
find it to be pleasant no
how is she unpleasant she was not
particularly polite
or accommodating to me or raquel or any
of amber's friends i wasn't there
specifically but i heard similar things
from amber and her interactions with her
as well throughout the course of our
time there
while you lived in penthouse one
did you have the opportunity to interact
often with amber hurt yes
did you and rocky see miss herd
frequently yes
did you ever see her drinking alcohol
yes
did you ever see her drink to excess yes
did you observe amber heard
during her wedding to mr depp at the
bahamas
yes
was she intoxicated at any time during
the wedding weekend yes
were we all
did you ever hear
at any time amber heard yell at mr depp
yes
on how many occasions
i couldn't tell you the number of
occasions
did you ever see her strike mr death no
did you and rocky ever discuss the
relationship between amber heard
and
johnny depp
yes on how many occasions
honestly probably hundreds if not
thousands
mr drew moving
to april 21
2016 you recall that there was to have
been a birthday celebration that night
yes was that
amber heard's birthday yes
do you recall which birthday it was for
her how old she was it was her 30th i
catered it
what do you recall about that evening
i recall it was held in ph 5.
johnny was hours late
and amber spent a better part of the
evening making excuses for him
and he came very obviously
intoxicated
and put on a show for everybody
and
when the party was over where we left
cleaned up
and
the next morning we heard about what it
transpired after the fact so johnny was
supposed to have attended the dinner
correct correct and at what time did the
dinner begin
i don't recall
you and rocky were guests at the dinner
correct who else was invited to the
dinner um
again you'll have to forgive me it was
quite some time ago i remember
amber's friend brandon being there
uh amber's friend iggy a rabbi
i want to say that whitney was there as
well
um
to be very honest i can't say with
specificity who else was there
when you say whitney are you referring
to whitney heard correct is whitney
heard amber's younger sister correct
putting aside the state for condition in
which johnny arrived do you recall
sitting here today approximately when
johnny arrived for dinner
i really couldn't tell you with any
specificity but i can say it was quite a
few hours after the party had started
did he provide any excuse or explanation
to the group as to why he was late no
putting aside mr depp's
intake of alcohol that evening
had miss heard been drinking before mr
depp arrived yes
do you know how much couldn't tell you
did she seem intoxicated during at any
time during the evening
yes
did you see amber heard the next morning
april 22nd 2016. i believe so yes
did you notice
any marks on her face or elsewhere that
morning i don't recall
that morning april 22nd
did you
and miss pennington
and amber heard drive together to
coachella
they did i did not
are you still in contact with amber hurt
sporadically yes
and and just just to be clear
when i'm sorry to jump around
when you say
are you
you say sporadically
how frequently you're in contact with
her we didn't speak for about two years
following my divorce
and she
reached out to me to make amends about
i want to say about two months ago
memory serves
i'm going to come back to that when you
said
you don't recall seeing marx on
the morning of april 22nd is that
because you didn't
see any marks on this order you didn't
see her at all that morning i i honestly
don't recall the state of her the next
morning if memory serves it was but that
the girls were hustling to get
everything together to go out to
coachella so it was a pretty frantic
morning i i couldn't say with any
specificity whether i interacted with
her that morning before they departed
and mr drew you said that miss heard
reached out to you when was when did she
reach out to you sometime in the last
two months
what did she say when she reached out to
you uh
to paraphrase it was something akin to
letting me know that you know her and
raquel were hadn't spoken in some time
and to tell me that she loved me and
that she missed me and she just wanted
to
make amends and
you know reconnect
did she mention anything about this
lawsuit not in the initial interaction
how did you respond to her in this
initial interaction when she said she
wanted to make amends i didn't for some
time i think i waited about a week and a
half before i responded and before i
could i did get a note from her letting
me know that she had tried to keep me
out of it but more than likely people
were going to be contacting me
either about being deposed under a
statement of some kind um there was
nothing explicit about whom it would be
coming from whether it was from johnny
side or from her side only that somebody
would more than likely be reaching out
to me
and when you had a glass of wine
again only lawyers remember these things
but do you recall approximately when you
had a glass of wine with her
probably about
five or six weeks ago
oh i'm sorry it would be longer than
that probably about two months ago
mr drew let's please change subjects and
move to
the evening of may 21 2016 which you had
referenced previously
was mr depp at the condo
of the east columbia building that day
prior to the evening that's my knowledge
did you see him arriving at the condo
that night no
did you see mr bette and mr judge that
evening yes when did you first see them
i saw them when he ordered them to open
the door to ph five following the
incident
when you say he to whom are you
referring johnny
did you ever see them that night
somewhere outside the door of ph3 no
do you know whether she received a text
from amber heard at 806 pm i can't
certify the time but the
text message itself and the receipt yes
were you with
rocky when she received that text yes
wasn't she already in penthouse three as
of eight of six pm
when she received the text she was not
in penthouse three she was in penthouse
five with me but again i can't i i can't
recall with specificity the exact time
of these events
any time including that night
did you ever see mr depp
strike rocky pennington no
that evening did you see
mr depp smash bottles of wine no
did you see him break furniture no
did you see him kick a hole through a
solid door no
do you recall
when mr depp mr bett and mr judge left
the building that night
if we're starting if
if we're presuming that that text was
received from raquel at 806
they had left the building within 30
minutes to my recollection
so it would be approximately
sometime
around 8 30 8 29
thereabouts but i don't recall
specifically
what else do you remember about
the events of the evening of may 21
i mean i can i can tell you
contemporaneously from the start if
there's something specific you'd like me
to expand on
who is officer melissa science
my understanding is the name of the
latina officer that first responded with
her partner
when did she arrive at the scene if you
recall
vaguely i remember them arriving about
45 minutes to an hour after
johnny left
but again
exact times i'm a little foggy
going back to the latina officer
was there another officer with her yes
there was a ball gentleman white
with which
officer if if any did you speak that
night both
what do you say them to them do you if
you recall when they arrived i greeted
them at the door
i walked them through ph3 to show them
the damage show them the broken glass
they had already walked through the
hallway over the gigantic wine stain
throughout the entire hallway
i took them through ph3 like i said to
show them the damage i took them back
out of the hallway showed them the dent
in the door shaped like the bottom of a
wine bottle in ph one took them into ph
5 to see
broken picture frames smashed glass
um raquel's jewelry and things like that
strewn about the apartment and then i
brought them back to ph3 at which point
they separated
the
latino officer pulled amber aside
specifically to speak to her one-on-one
the door was closed i was outside with
the other officer
so i can't say with any specificity what
happened
inside i don't know whether anybody was
in earshot i don't know what everybody
else was around they told me
specifically it was one-on-one and i was
outside the door with the mail officer
and
specifically my communication with him
was
asking what if anything could be done
because we were obviously upset and his
comment to me specifically was there's
damage in these apartments her face is
red if she wants to file a report we
have enough here to go pick him up
but you've never seen johnny hit
amber that's correct and i've affirmed
it to everybody that i've spoken to i've
been explicit about that and you've
never seen johnny hit any woman
correct
do you recall
having a conversation
with
rocky and amber
after
mr depp and his security personnel
left the building but before
officer science and officer hadn't
arrived yes
tell us about that
um
you'll have to forgive me again my my
memory of the exact circumstance of
events sequence events i'm sorry that
transpired after all this is is a little
foggy if memory serves
amber was
damn near catatonic after all this we
had gotten her into ph1 so we could
deadbolt the door and keep her safe
until he left
a few minutes thereafter i had gotten a
little bit of a run down from raquel
over what had transpired raquel got her
to call her lawyer samantha specter to
find out what to do
and if memory served samantha's
recommendation was that we immediately
put together a contemporaneous
um
matter-of-fact statement together of
what it transpired that night
and that ultimately was up to amber as
to what she wanted to do
with the police or
whatever it may be
are you aware that
amber heard spoke to officer science and
officer hadden that evening yes were you
present when she was speaking to them no
did amber file the complaint that night
no did the police arrest mr depp no
did they issue a warrant for his arrest
not that i'm aware of
mr drew let's turn for the moment to
may 22nd
2016.
did you see miss heard at all that day
yes
when did you see her
at various points throughout the day
if memory serves
raquel had committed to a jewelry show
somewhere
i want to say it was downtown it might
be mistaken it might have been on venice
somewhere in los angeles so she was out
most of the day so i
cleared my schedule to be able to
be there should amber need anything
if memory serves
either her attorney or somebody in her
uh in her group heard uh
had a friend come over with a locksmith
to change the locks just to be safe um
and i was there to make sure that that
happened and just like i said be there
for amber should she need anything just
so she wasn't alone
when you saw amber on
may 22nd you don't know whether it was
the morning or the afternoon
is that right uh
it was sporadic throughout the day i
think it was some point late morning and
throughout the afternoon when you first
saw her did you notice any marks on her
face yes
describe the marks please uh
to be very honest with you i don't
actually remember which side of her face
it was but i do distinctly remember and
there being a red mark and a small
bruise on her cheekbone
and red marks just above her eyebrow and
to the right side or to the side of her
eyebrow
did you see any
swelling
a little bit can you remember anything
else oh did you see marks anywhere else
other than the ones you've described no
did you ever notice anyone visiting
amber heard at night while mr depp was
away
during the time that i was living there
yes
yes
on how many occasions
i wouldn't even be able to estimate
was it more than 10 yes was it more than
20 yes
was it more than 30 yes
was it more than 50
again i
i can't really speculate i was there for
quite some time when did that first
occur
i mean i'm not again i'm not privy to
her comings and goings and
she had other friends than us that were
coming to see her
so
and again to be specific i'm just
talking about
visitors at night when mr depp was away
again i can't say with any specificity
when did that first happen that you were
aware of
i mean i would
say pretty early on but again i there's
no context to it
the other consideration that i would say
is that the hallway between all these
penthouses was public right-of-way going
to the pool so
my understanding of people coming and
going it might have been the public it
might have been residents i'm sorry not
public it might have been residents in
the building
i can't really say with any specialist
who was elon musk
elon musk was a gentleman that amber
dated intermittently following the
restraining order
when did you
do can you recognize elon musk yes
when did you first see elon musk
at penthouse 3
i'm a little
again i'm not quite clear exactly but i
want to say it was about
three to four weeks after
the restraining order was filed
but while
mr depp and miss heard were still
married correct
yes
after may 22nd
2016 did you ever see
any marks on miss heard
not to my knowledge no
would you please describe
as far as you can remember
what clean up
efforts were undertaken and by whom
uh
well myself
in penthouse 3 there was a number of
pieces of broken glass
and items strewn about the counters and
the floor in the kitchen
only in the kitchen sort of around the
kitchen island
and the hallway outside of the
penthouses was quite a bit of spilled
wine i don't believe we dealt with that
at all
and then in ph 5
all of raquel's things had been strewn
about uh pretty dramatically so we did
our best to sort of put that back
together and pack everything back up um
and there were you know things like
piles of books and picture frames were
broken and our positive books were
streamed out and picture frames were
broken and things like that we just
picked the glass up off the floor so the
dogs didn't get hurt and i think we left
everything else for the time being did
you actually see
who
strewn about
that's not the right verb do you
actually see the person who
threw her clothes around i didn't
witness firsthand any destruction of any
kind
are you aware that miss heard
alleged
that
mr depp
did her honor about december 15
yes
what if anything do you know about that
incident
so my
recollection of that is
raquel and i had come back to the
penthouses uh from where i don't recall
specifically sometime i want to say late
afternoon early evening
and
raquel was supposed to
meet with amber as soon as they came
back amber had not been responding to
her text messages for some time
so
we let ourselves into
ph
3 together to go check on her and make
sure everything was okay
when we came in
the
kitchen was completely i wouldn't say
it's trash but it was out of order
enough for something to be off
and then when we turned the corner on
the section of counter next to the
kitchen sink there was
something
written on the counter and
i don't know i can't remember what
material it was and to be honest i can't
actually recall exactly what was written
it was something very very weird like
always such a fraud or
something akin to that
you never saw mr debt
strike amber heard on her about
december 15 2015 correct correct um
did you see her
did you see miss heard that night yes
did you notice any bruising or
other signs of injury yes pretty
significant um
what did you observe
i noticed specifically she had um
she had pretty significant bruising on
the inside of both
of both eye sockets kind of extending
down the bridge of her nose
um and her forehead was red
but you have no first hand knowledge of
how that injury occurred that's correct
are you aware that she made a amber
heard made a television appearance the
next day yes
do you ever see mr duck
take drugs either prescription drugs or
drugs that were not by prescription yes
how many times
i can't speculate on a number of times
to be honest um there was some
questioning before what people were
asking you about emphasizing how many
times is it fair to say more than 10
times yes fair to say more than 20 times
yes
but to be very honest with you he was
also a very private person
and a lot of that behavior was done in
private i didn't witness a lot of it did
you ever hear mr depp
uh yell
at nisberg yes
um
can you tell me which when you recall
that and what happened
i can't tell i can't say with any
specificity the number of times there is
one
incident specifically that i do recall
myself and raquel were vacationing in
france with the two of them
and
they were
we were staying separately separate
houses
and the two of them were having a very
very loud argument with one another
screaming at each other that we could
hear through the walls how long do you
recall approximately that yelling lasted
for
i want to say
that i witnessed personally maybe 30
minutes did did mr depp often wear heavy
wings that you noticed on his fingers
yes
more than one
yes and when they were large is that
fair to say
if memory serves yes december 15
2015 los angeles california which is the
next page
uh and you'll see in paragraph 23 in
case it refreshes your recollection
there's a specific reference to
rocky
what knowledge do you have about this
incident
specifically
coming coming home i want to say late
afternoon early evening it was myself
and raquel melanie was not present
amber had not been responding to raquel
for some time they were supposed to hang
out the three of them
so we let ourselves into ph3
to check on her and make sure everything
was okay we came inside
the kitchen and the dining table were a
mess
like the kitchen like the kitchen island
area things were screwed about outside
of the norm
and there was something written on the
counter adjacent to the kitchen sink
like i stated previously something like
all was such a fraud or something in
that vein
um
we realized something was off right away
raquel told me to go back to our place
and then hooked it upstairs i didn't
hear from her for about 10-15 minutes
which i was obviously concerned about
the incident you just testified about
you talked about the kitchen being with
mr two about the kitchen being a mess on
what it's doing is this is the same
incident you were referencing correct
okay so i think you testified that when
you came and you saw some writing on in
the kitchen
um i've showed you a document which is a
photograph that we've marked as drew 10
and asked you if that's what you were
referring to earlier yes
um and did you come to learn
uh
mr drew who had written
this language
is the kitchen withdrawn is this the
kitchen counter it's yeah it's the
kitchen counter next to the kitchen sink
and this is in the apartment of ms hurd
and mr dub ph3
um and did you come to learn who had
written these words these words um in on
the kitchen comments i'm sure there'll
be an objection to this response but i
knew it's his handwriting when you use
the proposition his in that answer you
meant mr duff correct
um and why uh and are you saying that
you recognized at the time that it was
his handwriting correspondent and why do
you well how were you able to recognize
mr dubstand right now
he has a very unique
mode of penmanship
and you have seen that motive pensions
previously many times can you read uh
what is written on the countertop
um in drew 10
why be a fraud
all is such [ __ ]
um is this drew 10 an accurate uh
photograph of what you recall seeing
that day to my recollection yes
um
was anything else written on the
countertop
not that i remember
um
when you saw these when you came to the
apartment
and saw the mess in the kitchen and saw
these words
written
on the countertop
were you concerned immediately and what
were you concerned about
that something very very bad had
happened
and that's in part because you assumed
immediately that mr duff had written
these words yes
um can you read and oh you read into the
record what it says
just correct me if i'm wrong that little
kind of red thing there
in the top right hand corner of the
photograph
do you recall is that a lipstick
part of a lipstick i couldn't tell you
at the time did you have any idea of
what this was written in did you recall
looking at it i can answer i don't
recall from the time so i'm going to say
no
and i take it mr do you didn't take this
photograph no
do you know what rocky did i don't know
and when you say you were concerned that
something very
uh bad had happened what do you mean by
that
you walk into somebody's house and it
looks like they vandalized it and things
are
are amiss or things are strewn about
it's
doesn't portend anything good
did you go anywhere else
in
mr dap and ms hurt's apartment other
than the kitchen that day
the living room later
so again to the best of your rock action
i understand it's a long time ago and i
understand these aren't exactly happy
memories
but can you tell me
um
chronologically what happened you let
yourself into the apartment you saw this
just tell me the story again to the best
of reflection of what happened one how i
remember it is that we like i said we
came home late afternoon early evening
hadn't heard from amber in some time
which was out of character for her
let ourselves in to go check saw that
written on the counter saw the kitchen a
miss raquel looked at me and said
specifically go back to our place i'm
gonna go check on her bolt it upstairs
i was sitting over in ph one in our
apartment waiting
and i heard from her again i don't
remember exactly i want to say it was
about 10 or 15 minutes later
i really i really don't remember what my
response was i don't remember what
transpired after that
other than there was some time that
she was over there i don't remember when
or even if melanie came over at any
point during that evening what do you
recall about that and i remember it
specifically
because
she had pretty significant visible
facial injuries and didn't know
if she was going to be in a state to do
it or didn't know whether she was even
going to be
to have the the physical appearance to
be able to do it and when you say these
things first of all she in those
statements is amber heard yes did you
see who has heard face that day yes do
you have good vision
i i didn't have glasses and i didn't i
didn't need them then so yes so i'm
handing you a document that was marked
as through 11.
you can see from the top page it was
attached to ms heard's
affidavit declaration is exhibit 13. and
i want you to look at
the photos of ms hurt's face and tell uh
tell the jury
mr drew
if those were consistent with what you
observed on her face that day it is
i was with raquel when she took the
pictures
and uh the pictures were taking one on
raquel's iphone
or photo
to my recollection yes they they could
have been taken on amber's phone
so there wouldn't be any potential
accusation of bias or anything like that
and you described earlier to mr chu that
there was as i recall kind of
color under both of her eyes yes and i
say her eye name is heard if you look at
the one
two
three
four five
six photo
this one i'm going to hold it up
yes did you personally observe that day
this injury
on this hurts face
in december 25th i did
and you said before you were there when
ms pennington was taking the photo yes
there's a couple more photos in there it
looks like there's a busted lip
you see those photos yes do you recall
seeing that personally
on this hurts face that day
honestly i don't remember without
looking at this photo so i'm more
comfortable saying
i don't know okay mr drew were you there
do you this is a refresher recollection
you were then when all of these photos
were taken are just the photos of the
face i can't say definitively okay
um but there's some photos you were
there for that are here correct but at
least some of the photos in drew 11 you
recall being there and personally
observing this painting
correct
and
are you aware of any effort
by
rocky
or anyone else
to
manipulate the photos that were taken
that day with photoshop or any other
method of
changing a photograph if i had any
knowledge of that or even suspected it
this would be a very different interview
it's a deposition or a very different
deposition
whatever
i'm going to
turn now to
the incident on april 21 2016
in connection with
if you can mr drew is for you to tell me
in your own words
again separate and apart from anything
that's in
missouri's declaration what you recall
happening that day and what you did saw
and observed
so memory service it was amber's 30th
birthday she wanted to have a dinner
party at the
at the apartments just close friends
and i offered to cook dinner for
everybody
um
there had been some mention that he had
appointments or he had some things in
that but that he would be there and so
on and so forth i really don't recall
specifically
who the appointments with what they were
for what time they were anything like
that
quite frankly any type of schedule with
either amber or johnny was pretty much
to be very honest
[Music]
everybody arrived we were sort of
i think we waited for a little bit of
time expecting him to show up
and at a certain point
i think i don't know who made the
decision they were just like let's just
let's sit down have dinner he'll he'll
get here whenever he gets here
and
we had the party in ph five we sat
outside um
i want to say he showed up not towards
the end of the evening but pretty close
too um
again it's just my observation but it
appeared that he was inebriated in some
way i won't say whether he'd been
drinking on pills or whatever it was but
he did have the appearance that he was
any breed in some way
she did not react to it um
amber yeah played nice
he sat down
and honestly the rest of the evening was
quite pleasant he you know he does what
he always does when he comes and sits
down at dinner dinners put on a show and
connect with everybody and
you know be entertaining be pleasant and
polite and heard the same thing you
would have never known there was an
issue
and then
i didn't
hear anything until the next morning and
i knew that there was a scramble the
girls were leaving the next day for
coachella which i did not attend with
um
but all i knew was that they had gotten
a pretty big argument but because of the
rush to get out that day i didn't really
get too many stories about it
um you cooked the dinner that night
correct what'd you cook oh i don't
remember that
actually i do remember
i did i made tacos actually
don't ask me why i remember what i made
but i did amber wanted she wanted
mexican food so i did a big mexican
script
um
when you say that when mr
dev walked in he appeared and evening do
you recall was he swaying what do you
was his voice his words slurred what do
you recall um
because i had come to know him pretty
well at that point
he was
pretty good at hiding it
with people who didn't know him all that
well but you could sort of see that if
you spend enough time around with him
you can see the little ticks
slurring his words a little bit a little
bit extra
swaying being a little bit more
discombobulated and being a little bit
more um
what's the word like just gregarious and
loose it's not as normal mode
okay i hate
to
go back into what i'm going to refer to
as the poop incident
um but
i think you talked about earlier that
you observed
on a number of occasions
um dog
poop or dog pee
in mr dab and mister's apartment is that
correct in perpetuity
would you say in perpetuity it's pretty
much constant i've cleaned up my fair
share in that apartment um and i think
you testified that the dogs weren't
trained uh to only poop on the sidewalk
they weren't trained at all they had
their run and they'd be left at home for
a large portion of the day sometimes and
if there was nobody there to take care
of them
and at some point they it was peeing
poop on everything couches sofas
chairs
the bed you name it
let's go to the
may 21 incident which is covered on
babies 10.
uh through 13.
this is following
again same thing that we did for april
21 i would like it uh mr drew if you
could just tell me
the story of your role what you saw what
you observed what you did
chronologically in connection with this
engine
um i don't know what day of the week it
was it was either a friday or saturday i
want to say it was a saturday because i
was not in the office um
raquel had a jewel her first jewelry
show the next day and the plan was for
her and her friend liz who would come
over to to help her specifically get set
up for this
amber was around they were going to sit
in ph 5 and
do yoga and paint and
make necklaces and things like that and
i was sort of in and out most of the day
hanging out with them and pretty rapidly
thereafter i don't think it was more
than like
10 or 15 minutes before i heard
a door open in the hallway
and a couple seconds later i heard a
really really loud slam
which i later learned was a wine bottle
being smashed into our door ph1
and then i heard keys jingling and
johnny shouting at one of his security
to open this is it right if i swear i
mean i'm telling you here that's okay
you should say the words exactly as they
were saying as i remember he said open
this [ __ ] door get me in here
and he came in
caught eyes with me right away and
beeline for me screaming cursing
spitting my face
i walked calmly to leave
realized that i'd forgotten my keys and
the dog so i turned around and walked
back to go get both
he stayed and followed with me walking
pacing screaming cursing spitting my
face
and i left calmly at that point liz was
still in the apartment and the last look
i saw of her is that she bolted around
the corner and went upstairs to hide
from him
had mr
jeff ever done this to you before
no
did he
how close was he to you when he was
when he entered your apartment and was
screaming at you close enough for it to
be aggressive
um
is it a foot yes
and you said that you originally heard
him say you know open the [ __ ] door
when he was
spitting and screaming at you what was
what did you say
i couldn't tell you
honestly it sounded like gibberish at
that point i don't think i was really
hearing anything it was just how can i
get the hell out of here without
something else happening because quite
frankly like the reality
even though he's standing there from my
face he's also got you know two
bodyguards right there with them that
are bigger than me what's really going
to happen here
what what were you feeling when this was
going on i'm trying to i went i mean
i don't think honestly i didn't really i
didn't feel threatened i'll say that
flat out it just it seemed really really
silly i wasn't really surprised i just
wanted to get out and make sure that the
girls were okay
and sometimes uh you can say someone's
spitting at you because they're like
performing on a stage and there's she
wasn't like actively spitting in my face
it was just the nature of how close he
was and the way in which he was acting
um
okay
so
you go get your keys you get you guys
have your own dog i think yes you got
your dog
you
go out what happens next i walked down
to the hallway
and
to be very very candid i really i don't
remember in this instance whether i went
to ph3 to go check on them or whether i
went into ph one the sequence of events
after that as to when i actually
got to raquel and amber or whether they
came to me i really don't remember that
sequence of events offhand
i couldn't tell you so when you got to
raquel and amber what did you observe
i remember first speaking to them
specifically in ph one in our place but
how would it like i said how it is we
got there i don't remember i remember
dead bolting the door
and amber was like catatonic she was
just like a thousand yards there just
done and raquel was like trying to calm
down herself and i was like just what
the [ __ ] just happened
and she started to recount a little bit
and i went right out the door and
started banging on the door to do
something regrettable he was already
gone at that point
just so i understand that you banged on
the door ph5
i'm gonna go to one if you don't mind
but you're you're incredible
architectural drive mr drew so tell me
where you are where he was where you
went i was in here when johnny came in
doors door's right here the witness
should reflect i mean the records
reflect the witness pointing to ph five
door was right there this is in ph five
the living room's a little bit larger
i came out of the door
and door to ph one right smack in the
middle
and i went back started banging on the
door ph5 assuming he was still in there
but they were already gone
so what sparked you to go back to try to
go after mr duff was hearing from rocky
that mr duck had pushed her correctly as
opposed to his heart correct by the time
you got over there
um
he had already left yes
you said that that amber
when you saw them that amber and rocky i
think you said they ever seemed
catatonic yeah feel like she was just
a ghost
um
from what i remember sort of like uh
when somebody's coming down from an
adrenaline rush she was just sort of
like she didn't really know what to do
couldn't sit still
just sort of
standing there and shaking
um so after
[Music]
you had gone to try to find johnny you
already left what happened next i went
right back to the girls to make sure
that they were okay
after my own little selfish outburst
and they were at that point still in
your apartment they were still in my
apartment i came in amber started to
come out of it a little bit raquel
started to calm down a little bit i
started to get a little bit of
information as to what happens the thing
i remember most distinctly was that
amber had johnny's cell phone in her
hand so i took it from her
and when did you first learn about the
police
we were in ph one i believe at that
point when i came back upstairs amber
was already on the phone with her
attorney
we went back to go take pictures of all
the damage took pictures of the wine
stain in the hall is that the first time
you saw the damage in her place or had
you already seen it in kind of the back
and forth again i'm a little a little
foggy on that i want i can't say
definitively whether i've seen it before
or whether
that was when i saw it for the first
time so we took her back to ph3
we took photos of the damage inside
and i want to say the first responders
came
pretty shortly thereafter maybe
again i'm really guessing here i want to
say 20 or 30 minutes
at the most
the first set of police officers who
were there how long do you color sing
maybe 15 minutes i was asked to greet
the officers specifically because amber
didn't want to file a report and i said
that i would speak to them to see if
they if i could you know get them to
leave and say that everything's okay
even though we honestly we all knew
there was no way they could do that i
told her that i would go and greet them
first okay so two questions why did you
know that there was no way they could do
that question let me ask you that
question first
survivor of domestic violence myself
what was your understanding of why she
didn't want him she was still protecting
him
what else uh
if anything mr drew do you
remember either the female hispanic
police officer or the
caucasian gentleman saying uneven
um
i remember i was the one who walked them
through ph3 where the original incident
had occurred i showed them the broken
glass
they had already walked over the wine
stain in the hallway or the big spill of
wine and i showed them
the bolt in the door you could see
looked like the bottom of a wine bottle
i took them into ph5 and showed them
through their communication to me
throughout was me just pointing things
out to them the caucasian police officer
pulled me outside solo i can't say what
happened internally so i don't know
whether anybody was in earshot whether
it was just amber and the officer having
a one-on-one or whether there was
anybody else around them i don't know
what was said either specifically
outside of what i might have heard
second hand which has already been
talked about ad nauseam
you have in front of you
mr drew a series of photographs that
we've
marked as drew 13.
and i think i'm just going to take you
through them one by one if that's okay
with you
and i'm going to ask you if you remember
if you could tell me what these photos
are
these are photos taken of her uh
the night of the incident
who took the photos
some were taken by me some are taken by
raquel
and when you say the night of the
incidents
and are you sitting here today can you
distinguish
which were taken by you were taken by no
um
were you present when they were all
taken
i can't say that definitively okay um do
you present when photos were taken of of
ms hurt's face like you see on the first
page of this
yes
um and is this image of ms hurt's face
on may 21 consistent with your
recollection of what her face looked
like yes
and am i correct that unlike it's a
little hard to see because there's
shadow on the right but unlike the prior
incident that we looked at where there
were photos here
the injury looks like it's mostly on one
side correct
let's look at the next photo tell me if
you can remember
if you can identify with them
are
pictures pulled off the wall and placed
onto their bed in their bedroom let's go
to the next set of words clearer
do you recall
seeing this on the night of may 21. yes
this is on the column and ph5 going up
the stairs
um and there there the glass on the
pictures were shattered yes
starting with the first photo
of ms hurt's face is that what her is
that what ms hurt's face look like when
the police are up yes
uh
with the next photo of the pictures on
the bed and the broken picture frame on
the wall did you show these to the you
personally show these to the first group
of police officers at night honestly
this one i i really can't say whether i
did show them
to the officers i don't recall this just
so the record's clear you're pointing to
the photos on the bed correct what about
the photos on the wall
the third photo yes i showed them
personally for the photos on the wall
you had been in an apartment prior to
this yes was the glass broken when you
had last been in the apartment
this is broken glass i believe this is
from the landing directly beneath the
photo shown in the third photo and it's
a landing on a staircase yes
um
did you show
was that photo taken by either you or
rocky yes
did you show that glass to the police
officers who came the first group of
police officers who came that night yes
i did
um
take it even i can figure that out
that's the stairway
and um
that photo was again taken by india you
iraqi correct was the broken glass on
the stairway depicted in this photograph
showed to the first group of police
officers yes it was
um
what's the next photo
this is the hallway where there would
have been spilled wine right outside the
door of ph one and is do you see uh
spilled wine in this photo yes can you
indicate for the record where that is
uh here
and
here
and here
he's pointing uh to the sort of middle
of the photograph on the right side
on the floor
on the stripes um and was this a
photograph taken by either you or or
your young boy
yes
and uh
did the police officers the first group
of police officers who came see this on
that evening they would have walked
through it before they even got to the
door but that's not something you should
though no
um
last photo in the series
um can you tell me what that is
that is a wine bottle and spill the wine
on the floor
um is this a photo that was taken by
either you or rocky yes
um is this something that you showed the
first group of police officers that
evening yes
which apartment is this in i believe
this is in ph 5.
which room
in the living room
as i asked with the other series of
photos
that we
saw
first of all were any are you aware of
anyone who made any efforts to photoshop
or otherwise manipulate
these photos to make
uh
the incident and the circumstances look
worse than they would not to my
knowledge
do you have any understanding that
evening that looking at the first photo
of ms hurt's face that anyone had
somehow put makeup on her face to make
it look like she had an injury under her
eye so
with respect to these photographs
generally that we've looked at in drew
13.
was there any effort to stage the
photographs in any way absolutely not
um
and uh do you know how the photographs
got
ultimately tim is heard
i do not
so i think you testified earlier
um with mr chu
mr drew sort of rhyming here um that
um you uh were in contact in the
building
uh with ms heard on the day of may 22nd
yes and i'll represent to you that the
photos in drew 14 were taken on that day
uh see here today do you know who took
these photos we're talking about the two
i have in front of me right now yes
it was either me or raquel
um
is this consistent with your
recollection of how
ms heard
uh the next day on may 25th jackson
did you see ms hurt's face on may 22nd
yes did you or your ex-wife take photos
of ms hurt's face on that day
yes to my recollection
and
similar to questions i've asked in the
past was any
uh effort made to stage those photos in
any way not to my knowledge no was any
effort made to put makeup on this hurt
space to make the injuries look redder
or more serious not to my knowledge no
um was any manipulation of the photos
done either using photoshop or any other
similar method not to my knowledge no
i'm showing you a document that's been
marked as uh drew 18. i'm directing your
attention to the photos
uh there and asking if you can identify
uh where these photos were taken the
photo on the first page um
honestly i'm not sure i don't really
remember which stairwell this was from
from which penthouse each penthouse had
a stairwell yes
next one uh
both of these photos are taken from ph 5
where amber's closet was located
or whatever used as her closet i should
say
um
next page same thing amber's
closet same thing
next page at least the top one
top one same
bottom photo on that page
bottom photo is taken from it looks like
it's taken from the landing
on the stairwell of ph 5 towards the
kitchen towards the broadway side
um
and the next page seems like similar
copies um were you ever made aware
mr drew
of anyone destroying
amber hurt's closet this way
not to my knowledge are you aware of any
efforts
between and among
rocky pennington
io tillett
melanie iglesias
elizabeth mars or amanda de cadene
to quote get their story straight that's
my knowledge
have you had any outreach from any of
those people that i just mentioned to
you
to coordinate your story or your
recollection or your testimony about the
things you've testified here today no i
did receive a phone call from i o i want
to say
maybe three months ago that was
to catch up
and did you discuss during that phone
conversation your recollection of the
events that we've been discussing no
you testified
that the dogs were too small to climb
the stairs
and if the dogs in fact were too
small to climb the stairs
how would they be able to jump on the
bed one of them was one of them was not
so it's your testimony that one of the
dogs could have the ability to climb the
stairs and jump on the bed and the other
had neither correct
all right
ladies and gentlemen that completes the
testimony of that witness so we'll go
ahead and have our lunch break
again during your hour lunch break not
discuss the case with anybody and don't
do any outside research okay thank you
we'll see you in an hour
all right so we'll come back at 1 45
then is that fine
okay live witness at 1 45 so we'll take
the tv down okay all right thank you
foreign
so
[Music]
good morning good morning
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
another
[Music]
thank
these you are talking anyway i brought
this for you
guys thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
all right please be seated
all right your next witness your honor
we'd like to call whitney enriquez to
the stand all right
forward me
truthfully in this case
thank you all right thank you
will you please state your name for the
record whitney enriquez and where do you
live in glendale california
and you're amber's sister i am
are you how old are you
34. so you're her younger sister yes
okay are you married and do you have any
children i am i'm married with two small
children okay how old are your children
a three-year-old and a newborn he's just
over two months old
what is your profession
before the pandemic i worked in hotels
doing various food and beverage
management jobs primarily events as well
now i'm going to take you to
mr depp and amber the early stages when
did you first meet mr deb
i met him sometime in 2011 for the rum
diary press tour
but i did not meet him until
2012 as amber's boyfriend
and were you living with amber at the
time
yes we had an apartment together on
orange avenue
um i split my time between there as well
as a an apartment i shared with my
boyfriend at the time
now describe your relationship with mr
depp in the early stages
we got along really well at first um he
was sober at the time
and johnny whitney sober is very bright
and beautiful and lovely and kind and
generous and he was very easy to get to
know and frankly we all fell in love
with him
at first
describe your observations of amber and
mr depp's relationship in the early
stages
again at first that was
wonderful they were
incredibly in love i actually to this
day i've never seen my sister fall so
madly for somebody
um
and things were wonderful they seem to
really understand each other and get
along well and but very quickly this
pattern emerged uh as their relationship
went on that if johnny was using there
almost always was a fight there was
always an objection your header calls
for speculation like foundation
what if any changes in their
relationship did you observe
that when johnny was
using there would be a fight i saw it
firsthand objection your honor same
objection overruled this one thank you
please continue
if if he was using or if he was drinking
there was almost always a fight there
was always an argument there was always
a period where
they weren't getting along and it seemed
to oscillate pretty quickly he
would be sober for a little bit and then
almost just as quickly fall off the
wagon
and start to use or drink and there
would be some big blowout and it seemed
to go back and forth pretty frequently
there was never an extended period of
time where it was one or the other
what if any changes did you observe in
amber over the period of her
relationship with johnny
at first amber was
amber she was
she was loud fun funny she laughed a lot
she
was just this
happy bright
fun loving thing always surrounded by
friends
and then
it just it was a progression that took
over
such a long period of time and it was so
slow
in hindsight it was like watching a
slow-motion gunshot she suddenly stopped
sleeping as much she wasn't
as funny she wasn't as loud she wasn't
as gregarious as she used to be
cut to the end of their relationship
she
was so physically unwell she maybe
weighed 100 pounds soaking wet she was
emaciated she wasn't sleeping
she had developed a heart condition and
her eyes were sunken in she just looked
different
lack of foundation calls for hearsay
she's giving her observations heart
condition i'll sustain us to heart okay
other than the heart condition please
continue
uh she just if you were to do a
photograph side by side you would see
two very different people
and
people that knew her
throughout the entirety of their
relationships all the same thing
what if any observations did you
make about mr depp's
mr depp exhibiting controlling behavior
over the course of their relationship
relating to amber's clothing
objection your honor
what if any observations did she make
about how sustainable
what if any observations did you make
about
mr depp's
uh
treatment of amber relating to clothing
uh first
you know he would it would be like light
jokes or
you know she left the house wearing
something like oh you're gonna wear that
you know or just some joke it was very
subtle you know
and then over time again just like the
progression of their relationship it
just
intensified
then suddenly it's
you know she's
they have the same stylist he um
he and i i forgot her name
but um suddenly they have the same
stylist and he had been essentially
controlling what she wore to events and
things like that so she went from being
able to
wear whatever the hell she wanted and
then suddenly she's wearing
anything that her stylist his stylist
wanted her to wear
or wanted him to wear and her style over
time just got more and more conservative
what if any observations did you make
about mr depp
with respect to amber's work
that too was one thing at first it was
he was
saying he was protective over the kinds
of jobs she was taking you know oh
that's not going to be good for her
career that's not going to be good for
this not going to be good for that and
then suddenly it's he has a problem with
her taking any sort of job or any sort
of audition and then became every time
that she even thought about taking a
meeting it was another fight
he would often say things like i don't
even understand why she needs to work
i'll take care of her i'll take care of
you i'll take care of everyone else she
doesn't need to work at all it was one
of those things that he was at the end
vehemently against her working at all
what if any observations did you make
about mr depp's
treatment of amber with respect to
friends
uh that
again these are all things that just
very slowly over time just changed you
know at first
um you know he was very inclusive of all
of us at one point we all lived downtown
together in these beautiful lofts you
know at first it was that was part of
the relationship was
um getting to know him and him getting
to know us and then just again slowly
over time he took issue with brandon at
one point and then brandon wasn't
allowed in the fold
time went on he had an issue with io io
wasn't allowed in the fold anymore and
then at some point even me he had
accused me of doing something horrendous
that i had never done
and then suddenly i'm not allowed around
anymore and just over time she had such
a small network of people that were
there to support her
it was hard to watch
what if any observations did you make
about mr depp's
attitude
or treatment of amber with respect to
health
her health
amber was
she was a pretty healthy person at first
she didn't have any
any medical issues that you know didn't
need intervention of any sort
but in one of johnny's attempts to get
sober
he had employed
dr kipper who had these nurses
and
he had a personal nurse that would like
administer medication and you know i
think the intention was to make sure
that he stayed clean and objection your
honor calls for speculation
without discussing the state intentions
just go ahead and give us what your
observations were with respect to mr
depp with respect to amber's health sure
um all of a sudden for
really unclear reasons amber had uh her
own personal nurse just administering
medication and
i when i from what i saw it was strange
i didn't think he ever needed you know
medication on the daily or whatever and
then all of a sudden she has a therapist
that is employed by dr kipper
even her medical treatment was somehow
controlled by
or paid for by johnny objection your
honor uh calls for speculation with
respect to the control
west of control be paid for
love go ahead okay thank you
what if anything did mr depp say about
amber's electronic devices
well
every time they fought or had an
argument one a device was going to get
smashed
and she lost a phone a tablet
a computer you could almost guarantee
that something would get destroyed when
they fought
um
very often there were
fights were at least in part surrounded
by text messages or something that he
would find on her phones or you know
whatever and at some point she wasn't
even allowed to have
passwords on her phone or if she did
have a password it was something really
simple that he memorized but there was
zero expectation of privacy for her in
terms of what was on her device or
accessibility of her devices
how many times did you observe mr depp
drunk
uh i uh that countless i mean
uh too many times for me to quantify
how many times did you observe mr deb
high on drugs
again i it would be really hard to put a
number to that it was a lot
and what types of drugs did mr depp use
to your knowledge and your observation
well i
personally i've done cocaine and drink
with him on a number of occasions so
that
he almost always had weed of some sort
marijuana like you know joints or
whatever
[Music]
i have seen him take mdma
on an occasion shrooms as well
uh
i once saw him consume a bag a ziploc
bag that had a bunch of just unknown
pills some prescription some not he just
took them all at once to see what would
happen and he laughed about it
so i those are what i can recall
okay now you said that you also did
cocaine with mr depp is that correct yes
what if any observations did you make as
to what mr depp carried in his pockets
well
he always had
he always had cigarettes or rolling
papers
when i say cigarettes i mean the tobacco
and rolling papers he always had a joint
on him
if he was in a phase of using coke he
would carry around a little pill box
that had his cocaine in it
he always had a pocket knife
a lighter and
yeah it's about what i can recall okay
what if any behavior changes did you
observe when mr depp had been drinking
alcohol or using drugs
um
like i said it was you know a completely
different version you know
he was almost unrecognizable when he was
drinking and using to an excess
if it was alcohol and coke he would
he would slur he would go on these
paranoid delusional rants about things
that didn't make any sense he
you know
his speech would be slurred i almost
never knew him to use cocaine without
drinking those were generally
combined
when he would smoke weed he was much
more relaxed he was kind of what you
would expect happy on a couch laughing
but when he was drinking
he would just get very angry and he
would just say really nasty unkind
things and it almost didn't usually
about amber sometimes about me but it
almost didn't matter if she was in the
room or not he would just say
really horrible
horrible horrible things about her or to
her
can you give the jury and a few examples
that you can recall
pardon my language [ __ ] [ __ ] he
called her a [ __ ] used up trash bag
uh
slimy [ __ ]
saggy [ __ ]
uh just
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] was
thrown out a bunch
just horrible things like that
i'm going to take you to march 21st 2013
we've called it
the painting or keith richards incident
when did you arrive at the orange
apartment
on march 21st 2013.
um it was sometime in the afternoon
sometime in the afternoon
i came in and
orange was typically a very neat clean
place but as soon as i walked in
there was a bunch there was smoke in the
air remember there's
it smelled like cigarette smoke and
there was smoke in the air so somebody
had been smoking inside which was odd
because amber and i don't smoke and
johnny used to always just go outside to
smoke
um but walking a little bit further in
there was like furniture askew
going into the kitchen there was you
know
johnny was sat at our little breakfast
nook table that we had there
and he was wearing glasses he had you
know there was
cocaine in front of him there was out
booze in front of him
journal like newspaper things like that
just kind of scattered around
at the table
and i sat down to
talk to him to see what was going on
and it was really hard to understand
what he was getting at it was really
clear that he had been drinking for some
time his speech was slurred and
again he was really it was really hard
to follow what he was trying to tell me
at first he seemed to be upset that
my sister had been photographed with our
friend marie in france
uh he then started saying that it must
have meant that she was having an affair
with her and you know everyone would be
laughing at her and
um
this woman her father was a french
politician so he then starts rambling on
about oh he knows what her her father is
up to and her the satin the other and
again it was just this strange paranoid
tail spin is the only way i can describe
it that just it wasn't true my sister
wasn't having an affair with this person
objection your honor i think is pretty
non-responsive at this point
all right all right next question please
sustain the objection please describe
what your conversations were and your
observations were with mr deb
um
so uh as i'm sitting there talking to
him amber is in the kitchen and you know
she's not sat at the table or anything
she's kind of hanging back and
johnny's still talking to me about
what the problem was and then all of a
sudden the focus shifts to this painting
that has been on the wall
ever since amber and i moved in and the
painting was done by one of my sister's
exes
so he was convinced that it was on the
wall
to taunt him to tease him and how
disrespectful that he had to wake up
next to this painting and it surely
meant that amber and tasha were back
together again which of course was not
true
but he was then upset about that he was
upset about this painting that was on
the wall
we
had
i was trying to talk to him not only to
just try to figure out what was going on
but i was trying to get him out of the
house because he was already very late
for
uh filming this documentary that was
being shot at one of his houses was that
with keith richards correct okay that
was my understanding of it please
continue
um
so for hours we sat there i was trying
to you know talk to him
make him feel like everything was okay
just try to get him out of the house he
his assistant kept coming in and out at
one point
and all the while amber is just in the
kitchen she's
again she's like giving us space but
she's an ear shot and he's saying these
things about her
and at one point she tries to come over
to like check on him and she kind of
embraces him raises him from behind and
he's just like [ __ ] off and
you know continues to say these things
about her
and again we sat there forever and
eventually we did get him to
leave the house so
um i but he insisted that amber come too
and that if they were going to work it
out she'd have to be there and they
would talk about it at some other point
i guess let me just stop you for a
minute what if any injuries did you
observe on amber at that time
at the time i it was before i had a real
understanding of what
was going on it was pretty
i didn't know frankly i and her face was
swollen and
but i didn't and it was kind of red i i
thought she had just been crying
um and her lip did appear to be cut but
again that at the time it wasn't what we
were trying to do it wouldn't have been
appropriate to you know talk to her
about it or anything that wasn't my
focus frankly my focus was just sitting
there trying to figure out what he was
upset about and get him out of the house
so how long were you at orange with mr
depp and amber before he left to go to
the keith richards a few hours um
i couldn't say
maybe around like four or five hours
okay it was a it took a minute
now did you accompany mr depp over to
the recording or did you stay
i did um
and amber did amber go to correct that
was that was part of the condition of
him leaving he is that amber had to go
with us all right well please describe
to the jury what happened next then on
your ride over there
so amber and johnny were sitting in the
back
i was in the front with
sterling the driver
and
i
they weren't saying much back there
there was music playing pretty loudly
so i couldn't really
hear what was going on back there
um but at some point i heard the back
door open or the back window open and
johnny is holding our dog out the window
and i
i froze i was scared because i just
remember thinking i knew how inebriated
he was and if and the dog was very small
i thought if she twitched or you know if
he lost her somehow she was just gonna
go out the window
um
and amber of course was just saying
objection your honor
um not after prove the truth of the
matter asserted your honor i'll sustain
the objection okay don't say what amber
said just go ahead and continue with
your observations he brought the dog
back into the car
um and he was just laughing this really
scary loud
like it was almost like a cackle and um
he then made some joke about putting her
in the microwave
and that was the joke after that was
putting the dog in the microwave okay
so
during
the year
2013 what if any
marks did you
observe on amber any injuries or signs
of markings anything like that
occasionally i'd see
bruising
cut lips split lips
weird marks burns or i don't know on her
arms scratches on her arm things like
that it was just
it was just weird and it was periodic it
wasn't like a a constant thing but there
were
there were injuries to her and and what
if anything did you do did you ask her
about them
i did at some point confront her and ask
her and she objection your honor hearsay
don't tell don't tell any objection next
question okay
but you did ask her about them
yes objection or same objection next
question
that's okay thank you your honor um all
right i'm going to take you to june 2013
hicksville
were you in attendance at that event
with mr depp and amber yes yes please
describe for the jury what you can
recall from that event
so hicksville is like this um
it's just like collection of themed
airstreams it's like a little uh it's in
the middle of the desert it's just like
a fun little place to go so we went with
a group of our friends
um
and yeah so each one of us had our own
little airstream or whatever so
my partner and i at the time we got
there last
so as we're going around checking out
the different air streams because again
each one of them had a different theme
so it was kind of fun to see you know
who was staying in which theme or
whatever
um i opened amber and johnny's and
there's cocaine on the table
and i didn't really think much of it at
the time i was just like all right fine
we're all here to have fun
um
and that night you know we sat around
the campfire
uh everyone was drinking some people
were taking shrooms
you know
and then i i drank too much and i went
to bed early before everyone else
um and then the next day
uh
you know when everyone was cleaning up i
i had heard about something that had
happened the night before
and an altercation that objection your
honor here don't tell us what you heard
go ahead and just tell the jury what you
observed
i observed people cleaning up after what
appeared to be just a night of friends
hanging out
um i then went to my sister's trailer so
you know where she was staying with
johnny and it it looked like a bomb went
off in there there was
broken things uh things have been skewed
it just
looked incredibly messy it looked like
somebody had ransacked it
um
that's what i observed okay
now i'm going to take you to september
2013
what if anything did you do with mr depp
relating to
going to london
so september 2013 that was
around the time of my birthday
amber was filming in london
and
she wasn't able to make it back for my
birthday and it was also a friend of
ours io also has a birthday the same
time or around the same time as
me
and
johnny thought it would be great to
load up and surprise amber on set
he thought she'd really enjoy it and
so that's what we did we loaded up we
went on a plane that he chartered and uh
i believe my father was with us as well
and yeah johnny and i
drank and did a lot of cocaine on that
plane and i ended up passing out but we
get to london and you know we had it was
it was wonderful to see amber and
uh we had a dinner that night at the
hotel that we were staying at or it was
either that night or the next night i
can't remember exactly but
um
at one point johnny picked up a steak
knife and he hurled it at his assistant
um
missed him but
obviously nathan got upset and he left
and he was upset as well
and i
a fight broke out between amber and
johnny that night
uh i didn't
i didn't witness it i wasn't there i
just i knew objection
so you can't tell us about it if you
weren't there so what happened next that
you were aware of
i left some time after that and when i
touched down um
in los angeles i
i learned that they had objection
not effort to prove the truth sustain
the objection next question
when did they get
engaged
they got engaged at some point when i
was on the plane i left london by the
time i landed in london they were
engaged okay thank you
now i'm gonna jump all the way to
november 2014.
the 2014 hollywood film awards
what if any involvement did you have
with mr depp relating to the hollywood
film awards
i was called over to
where he was getting ready 80.
um and when you when you say 80 are we
talking about sweet sir yes that's one
of the houses that is on
uh
that street that johnny had he had
several houses on that street 80 was the
one that um he referred to as like the
man cave that's where he spent a lot of
time
um so i was summoned to 80.
again following a fight that he and my
sister were having and objection your
honor lack of foundation
i
just go on just don't talk about what
you weren't party to
you got there please tell the jury
okay please tell the jury what you
observed what happened when you were
there sure uh when i got there
johnny was uh was outside and he was
very drunk already and he was continuing
to drink
he was again
rambling about my sister having affairs
with
people that
it just wasn't true and just kept saying
things it was you know that she doesn't
need to work and i he doesn't understand
why she continues to take jobs she must
be doing it to insult him or to hurt him
or she's only taking these jobs because
she if she wants to meet people i don't
know
the entire time that we were talking his
sister
and his um
you know uh assistance at one point
everyone was trying to get him out of
the house uh because he was already very
late for this
um but eventually they did get him to
leave the house
and
yeah i
saw the award show later at some point
and what did you observe when you
watched the awards show
unfortunately an extension of what i had
seen at the house he was still very
drunk
actually a little bit more drunk than
when i saw him at the house
and what was he doing to caused you to
believe he was very drunk well he was
drinking the entire time that we were
talking
and you know in general at this point i
i had understood what johnny looks like
when he's drunk he's stammering he his
speech was
hard to understand he was slurring he
was super unsteady on his feet
uh yeah i just i recognize what he looks
like when he's drunk okay
now i'm going to take you to march 23rd
2015.
um
and at this time
were you living at the penthouse suites
i was
excuse me
when approximately did you move into the
penthouse
suites
uh
i want us i actually don't know for sure
when i moved in
i would take me a minute to remember it
was sometime in 2000 um
i'm 14 i think okay
and so as of march 23rd 2015 you're
living there correct
yes and and where
where are you living in those penthouse
suites what is it called so i was in
what they call ph4
the layout is you know the entire top
floor of this building um johnny owns
the mall and he was kind enough to let
us all live there so
i was i was in ph four
amber and johnny were in ph three
um i believe isaac was in two and rocky
and josh were in one
but the only ones that actually
connected were
three four and five
so again i was kind of sandwiched
between where johnny and amber stayed
and amber's basically
closet so basically you had to cut
through to get to one point to the other
um so i was sleeping i woke up to
amber in my bedroom saying can you
believe he's cheating on me objection
your honor you're not offered to prove
the truth of the matter
thank you thank you plea please continue
uh she said something
she said she said overruled it's okay
for you to say what oh sorry brief just
briefly what you just explained she i
woke up to her saying can you believe
he's cheating on me your [ __ ] brother
is cheating on me
i got up i told her to
stay right objection your honor hearsay
it's not offered to prove the truth of
the matter
ruled for that statement go ahead
please continue i instructed her to stay
in my apartment while i go
and talk to johnny um
so i i leave ph4 i leave her in ph4 and
let me just stop are you sober drunk
have you been drinking
oh rare occasions where i was sober
i was i was i was it was in the middle
of the night i was asleep
so i'm sorry i'm not sure that i
understood your question so you were
sober oh absolutely yes yes okay
please continue
so i go to ph five where um
amber i'm sorry johnny
um debbie and travis were all standing
in the kitchen
of ph five
i was i went down there to talk to him
and again i can i can tell he's clearly
drunk
and he has a bottle of uh of alcohol
some sort in front of him as well
and again he's talking to me about how
he
how amber found these text messages
between him and a woman
uh called rochelle and then he started
saying that this woman was meaningless i
was just it wasn't anything special
she's nothing special but then he
immediately shifted to
well amber amber pushed me ever made me
do it and of course i'm cheating on her
you know whatever and it suddenly became
about amber making him do it
um at some point then amber is on the
mezzanine level of ph five so she is
it's kind of hard to explain so the
kitchen's down here and the mezzanines
up here
so
she's there it's her little office no
can she start shouting at him
uh saying objection you're on her
hearsay it's not offered to prove the
truth of the matter asserted your honor
she's screaming expletives at him i mean
that's not operational
thank you
they're saying horrible things to one
another
[ __ ] you
you know he's calling her a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
used up
trash bag you know whatever they were
saying horrible things to one another
she was calling him old and fat
it was a fight they were saying really
nasty things to one another
i leave them in the kitchen to go up the
stairs was trying to
calm amber down hopefully get her back
into my apartment
and
debbie had come up with me
and debbie who's debbie debbie was his
nurse
uh yes i believe that was her name
um
so we're with amber on the mezzanine
level i'm sorry just so we know who
where is is it you and debbie that are
with amber or yes debbie debbie amber
and i are all in the little mezzanine
area
um and as i mentioned the mezzanine
looks overlooks the the kitchen in the
living room
so
johnny then hurls a red bull can and it
hits debbie in the back she didn't even
react she didn't really seem to notice
um
but i'm i'm standing up there talking
i'm standing up there i'm at the top of
the stairs with my back to the stairs
and that's when johnny runs up the
stairs and my again i'm facing amber
he comes up behind me
strikes me in the back
kind of just somewhere over here he
strikes me in the back i hear amber
shout don't hit my [ __ ] sister
she smacks him lands one
and then he grabs at that point that's
when travis runs up the stairs after
amber landed one and but by that time
johnny had already grabbed amber by the
hair with one hand and was whacking her
repeatedly in the face with the other as
i was standing there travis pulls them
apart i get amber into mine i close the
doors behind me and lock them
i then hear johnny's voice shouting
never mind twitch okay sorry i hear
johnny's voice shouting you i [ __ ]
hate you i hate you both you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] and i hear
crashing i hear crashing and banging and
smashing and he starts screaming like an
animal
and
i then just moved amber into the next
room and i just kept her there all night
the next day i go and i see her closet
has been completely destroyed
um
racks were overturned yeah one of the
closing clothing racks had been like
tossed down the stairs there was art off
the wall
and down in the kitchen there was broken
glass like it just
the place was destroyed
michelle can you bring up defendants
exhibit 400
whitney do you recognize this this text
exchange here i do okay and it's on
march 23 2015 at 6 57 is that correct
yes okay could you describe object
identify it please yep sorry on here say
grounds
all right you want to approach
so this is uh
can we publish your honor
yes
thank you
so whitney this is dated march 23rd 2015
657 do you see that
okay and that's to kevin
who's kevin
kevin murphy he was johnny's estate
manager okay
and then michelle if you can scroll up
so let's stop at the first one can you
please describe to the jury what this is
that is one of amber's clothing racks um
on the stairs that lead up to
the
bedroom area
okay and you took this picture i did
okay michelle can you scroll up again
and please describe for the jury what's
depicted in this photo these are more of
amber's racks they these were her shoes
and purses and such those were all like
taken off the walls
and you can see here all of her clothes
are on the floor
our shoes
okay thank you
and
we're up to the next one could you
please describe what the next picture
depicts more of the same uh clothing
racks that have been
kind of toppled over or moved um they
used to they were like neat it looked
like a you know it's a closet room but
these ones were just toppled over and
moved
this is the room that had joined my room
so
okay
let's go to the next one
and could you describe for the jury
please what this is
that's another clothing rack that has
been taken down and taken apart kind of
okay
and we'll go to the next one and please
describe for the jury what's depicted
here
more just more clothing racks that have
been taken down moved
okay
and please describe for the jury what's
depicted here
same thing just more clothing racks that
were toppled over
all right and
we go to the next one
and this is the kitchen area this is the
ticket from the mezzanine level that i
was describing earlier but that looks
like broken glass
or something blue ceramic broken
okay and if we go up and the top one
there looks like part of what was
earlier let's go to the bottom when i
think we have a bigger picture there
does that help
with what's depicted there
i still can't tell what it was maybe a
plate of some sort but there's also
a rolled cigarette couple bottles of
water but yeah whatever that blue thing
is it was broken that's what's all over
the kitchen there and also next to the
stove
okay
thank you
after the staircase incident uh what if
anything did mr depp ask you to sign
uh there was an nda on my kitchen table
can you tell the jury what an nda is
it's a non-disclosure agreement it's
basically um my understanding is it's a
contract to
keep things private to
keep your mouth shut essentially
all right and you were given one or
asked to sign one i was asked to sign
one um i don't i did i don't believe i
signed it i left some time after so you
moved out after that
it was yes it was after this point that
johnny had accused me of
selling stories to the media which
were absolutely untrue but i moved out
after that point okay
now did there come a time that amber
asked you to move back in
yes
february
2016. she texted me asking me to come
back okay
and
so so you were living with her from
february sometime in february 2016
forward
i think on and off i think i had my own
apartment by then but i spent a lot more
time at the eastern after that okay
i'm going to take you to april 21 2016
amber's 30th birthday party were you
present for that i was can you please
describe to the jury what you observed
that night
it was her 30th birthday so we wanted to
make it
excuse me really special
we had made this beautiful dinner
you know and it was it was great all of
her close friends were there
and um everyone was having a really good
time everyone was having fun um
you know johnny
showed up very very late
um
and he was drunk when he showed up
um amber was obviously upset about it
but
um there came a time in the party where
we all went around the table and said
our favorite thing about amber you know
just funny memories or whatever
when it came to johnny's turn he
told this story about how they first met
when uh they met for the rum diary so
you know he had the story about how she
came in
to his office and she sat on the couch
and she her perfect ass left a perfect
imprint on the couch and he wouldn't let
anyone sit there after she left that day
and it was one of those stories that
i everyone was kind of embarrassed you
know we had all gone around the table
saying really nice things about her and
gets to him and he's talking about her
ass
we were all kind of embarrassed
and
when did you leave the party that night
i left uh pretty shortly after that okay
and i went home
what if any conversation did you have
with mr depp about his plans to attend
coachella the next day
he was planning on coming
to coachella with us um
you know
at some you know whenever at some point
we were talking about what was happening
the next day and
so that night he told us he was going to
come to coachella with us the next day
okay
and did he ultimately come to coachella
with you the next day no okay
i'm going to jump forward to talk about
some statements that were made the
counter claim
um
what if any observations did you make
about how
the statements were talking about the
three statements from that
were quoting adam waldman
uh
impacted amber and i'm asking for your
observations just tell the jury
what your observations were of how these
statements impacted amber
objection your honor uh compound lack of
foundation speculation overruled
amber has worked so hard to
overcome
everything that she went through in the
duration of their relationship she
really really tried her best to move
past it
and
anybody that knows amber at all knows
that
some of the most important things to her
are honesty integrity it's her
reputation is all she has
she doesn't have piles of money in
private islands or objection your honor
it's non-responsive sustainable i
sustain the objection
i'm pleased she was
she was devastated
by these she
to say that they're not true
it it devastated her and also we had
just buried our mother um
you know so
amber she started having panic attacks
randomly she was not sleepy objection
your honor hearsay
these are your observations thank you
plea please continue
these statements devastated her
they devastated her because they weren't
true and
they were just very very very much
affecting her
and you talked about panic attacks what
else did you observe that that she would
do as a result of these
a physical
she would just like hurt like
periodically just break into tears she
she
i don't know how else to describe it she
was she was
she was so unwell she stopped sleeping
again she
was super anxious she couldn't she
couldn't relax she couldn't sit still it
was very similar to the amber that i had
seen back in 2016 as she was trying to
get out of this relationship
it launched her back into
this space where she was just so
physically unwell and
she she cried a lot
thank you i have no further questions
all right cross examination
good afternoon ms enriquez
uh we haven't met before my name's
rebecca lecoros i'm one of the lawyers
representing mr depp in this case
um you grew up in texas with your sister
and your parents right correct
and you were really close with ms hurd
growing up we were
and you're still close now right we are
and you love her
of course
and
your childhood though had some difficult
moments right
it wasn't perfect
your father hit you and your sister at
times right
yes
and your sister would protect you from
that abuse when she could wouldn't she
we would protect each other for sure
and when you graduated from high school
you moved out to los angeles right i did
and your sister gave you a place to live
in l.a
yes
and she helped support you
um
in part i also was working myself and
yeah
and you're grateful to her for being
there when you needed her right
of course
and just like she protected and cared
for you you want to protect and care for
her right
she
and when i can of course but
yeah
um
you uh testified to having a great
relationship with mr depp when you first
started dating your sister right correct
and you thought of him as a brother
yes
he called you sis
yes
and you had affectionate nicknames for
him too didn't you a number of them yes
yeah
and you testified that for a time you
lived in the ecb penthouses um with mr
depp and miss heard that's correct
and mr depot in those penthouses he did
you didn't pay rent while you were
living there right no you didn't pay for
any of the bills for the penthouses no
it's very generous
and rocky pennington lived in one of
those penthouses also right she did and
at some point her boyfriend josh drew
moved in right yes
and isaac brooch
lived in one of those penthouses too yes
and you know that he testified here that
you call him your spirit animal right
i did not know that but
yeah he's wonderful
you call him a spirit animal
uh at one point i did yes
you took trips with your sister and mr
depp also right occasionally
you didn't pay for those either right
nope
i did not
during the course of mr deputies heard's
relationship
you were frequently involved in their
arguments weren't you
yes
in fact you had a nickname right
marriage counselor yes
um you often felt found yourself
mediating disputes between mr depp and
miss heard right
clearly not very well but yes
and
when you were in that role of marriage
counselor you empathize with mr depp
right
yes on occasion
because you had a pretty good
understanding of what he was going
through it depended on the situation
sometimes i could totally see from his
perspective other times i saw it from
her perspective but you'd been there
with miss herb before right
we're sisters of course we've argued
and you knew what it was like to want to
run away for days and do your own thing
and not have ms heard they're fighting
with you right
i think that's kind of taken out of
context a little bit i you know
i think more metaphorically
um but yes i have i have been in
arguments with my sister
and you have wanted to run away for days
right
sure and not have her there fighting
with you
sure
you talked a little bit about the
incident in march 2013 right
which one that was the one before um you
went to the keith richards documentary
set and you were present with mr depp at
orange that day i was
um didn't you do cocaine with mr depp
that afternoon yes
and
you said mr depp's already intoxicated
he was by the time i got there and he
was fighting with your sister
he wasn't doing much of anything he was
sat at the table he was telling me about
the fight that they had
so he was kind of he'd been fighting
with your sister that day when you
arrived that was my understanding and
you said she had a puffy face
yes
and despite all of that you decided it
was a good idea to do miss cocaine with
mr deb at that juncture hadn't yet
connected the dots i hadn't yet
understood what that meant or what that
would do that was a yes
yes you took cocaine with mr deputy i
did yes i already said that
um you testified that you had suspicions
uh that mr depp was allegedly hitting
your sister
by some point 2013 right
suspicions
and notwithstanding that in june 2013
you were actually joking with mr depp
about hitting your sister right
regrettably over a text message yes you
were encouraging him to hit her
i was not literally encouraging him to
hit her but you were joking about it
regrettably yes again lex
i did not have an understanding fully of
what that was i never would have said
that now knowing what i know
but that was a legend that was around
the time that you allegedly became aware
that he was
i don't know injuries on your sister
that caused you to have suspicions i
don't know if it was around the same
time
turning to the um the staircase incident
in march 2015.
um you testified that mr depp allegedly
hit you during that incident right
yes but you weren't sure if that contact
was even meant for you right i honestly
don't i don't know what he was aiming
for my back was to him and you weren't
injured during that incident right no i
wasn't
and you didn't seek medical attention
no
and you said debbie lloyd was there
during all of that correct she was and
mr depp's security travis mcgivern was
there too yes he was
and you saw your sister hit mr depp on
the stairs that day right
after he struck me yes
you said she she landed one right
and then the next day you found some
damage in the adjoining penthouse
correct and we saw some pictures of what
you saw that day right yes
you thought it was important to document
that damage right
not to document um it was kevin's job to
kind of clean up the houses take care of
the houses
i took pictures just so he could be
aware of what he would need to bring
i didn't know if he had tools here or
whatever i was just preparing him for
what he was going to have to fix
but you didn't take any pictures of your
sister that day right
no i didn't
now after march 2015 you continued to
have a close relationship with mr jeff
right
yes
and you still loved him
of course
and you were there for him if he needed
you right
of course
and in fact just a couple of weeks after
that staircase incident you were still
acting as the marriage counselor weren't
you
at some point sure
and
that fall after the staircase incident
october 2015
you claim you had seen mr deb hitting
your sister and then in october 2015 you
were actually still trying to reconcile
him and your sister when they were
fighting right
yes i was
asked to support i was just trying to
help
what i thought they both wanted
i was just trying to support trying my
best to support them the way that i
thought i could
you still love mr depp at that point
right
i did
and you didn't think that he and your
sister were past the point of no return
right
what i thought was irrelevant at that
point i
i really
those two were in love and they were
working very hard
they wanted to be together it seemed
like so
i
i just helped as best as i could i don't
know how else to describe it you're just
your sister still wanted to be with mr
deb right
she loved him
and you didn't think they were past the
point of no return
i don't know what you mean by that
exactly okay
um
let's take a look at um planus exhibit
1283 it's not yet in evidence so we'll
just show that to the witness
i've got this
if i might approach your honor i have
this in redacted and unredacted okay if
you want to come forward
and
uh ms enriquez if i could just direct
your attention uh we can go to the third
page please
do i have control of this or no no you
do not sorry we'll put it up for you
and
we can go back to the to the first page
if you'd like or we can take a look at
the unredacted version if we need to but
do you recognize these as text messages
that you sent to mr depp on
october 2nd 2015
um
yeah vaguely i mean they're clearly my
text messages but
yeah i recognize them i think okay and
if we can go to the third page please
tell
and you'll see that the second blue box
from the bottom there
you texted mr depp and you said i love
both of you so much
and would [ __ ] stay out of it if i
thought this [ __ ] were past the point of
no return
but that's not where you guys are right
now
did i read that right
oh but that's not where you guys are at
yes
so you didn't think they were past the
point of no return in october 2015 right
at that point clearly i didn't
you wanted miss her to stay with mr depp
even after you allegedly saw him hit her
right
that's really oversimplifying something
that's far from simple
um again
amber was very much in love so was
johnny
she's telling me that she wants
something
whether or not i agreed to it or not
whether or not i was okay with what was
happening
it wasn't my place if my sister said
that she still wanted to be with johnny
and
if i could help with that in any way i
was going to support her i was going to
be there for her to support that yeah
you didn't want to contradict your
sister right
pardon you didn't want to contradict
your sister
i don't know if i'd characterize it that
way i just again i was trying to support
my sister the best that i could or knew
how or thought she wanted
and you say you wanted to protect her
though right
at that point
i don't know if i would categorize it as
that i was just trying to support my
sister you went to coachella with your
sister for her 30th birthday in 2016
right yes
and you testified that you were aware um
i believe that she and mr depp uh had
fought the night before
you get to turn your microphone on this
brighter house
okay withdrawn all right you can answer
the question man yes i was aware that
they had argued the night before
you didn't see any bruises on miss hurt
at coachella that year though right
you know she was wearing a lot of makeup
you didn't see any marks on her
not that i can recall didn't notice any
swelling right
to the best of my recollection i don't
and your sister didn't have a working
phone on her that day did she
no she didn't
but you did
yes it did
and you wanted mr depp to know that um
ms heard's phone wasn't working right
i believe i reached out to him for her
yeah
and you were encouraging him to reach
out to her through you
if he was trying to reach her right i
believe so at one point yes
you didn't want him to think that he was
ignoring her
sorry you didn't want him to think that
he was ignoring her right
sure
um and you wanted them to reconcile
didn't you
amber really wanted him there
despite the fact that they had had a
fight the night before
it was very complicated it was very
nuanced you know they thought they got
back together they fought they loved
each other they hate each other they
loved each other
i just remember her wanting johnny to
come to coachella at some point
i wasn't trying to reconcile them i was
just trying to
help facilitate
and you did that even though
you were concerned about marx that you
say you'd see an honor since at least
2013 and during the course of their
relationship right again that's really
oversimplifying something
we all saw this
we all thought that johnny we would see
johnny on the other end of this because
again when he was sober things were
wonderful
when they weren't when he wasn't sober
they were terrible sure but we all
thought that he was just going to get
better we all wanted to just see the
other side of that so yes sure if you
look at it simply
but it's not simple at all
i
don't know how else to answer it and
this was after you allegedly saw him hit
her right
yes
and you knew that they just had another
fight right yes
you know who jennifer howell is right
miss enriquez i do
she's the founder of the art of elysium
nonprofit
she is
and you worked there for a time didn't
you i did
around may 2015 you actually moved in
with ms howell right
may
2015 yes
and you moved out of the penthouses
because at that point you and your
sister were fighting right
it was yeah it was around the time that
you know he had accused me of leaking
stories and that was the impetus of me
leaving
and you testified earlier i think that
he had asked you to sign an nda right at
some point and that was around the same
time that he was concerned you were
leaking stories about their wedding to
the media
i believe so
um you and ms howell were close
we were close enough that you lived with
her for around a year
i don't recall if it was that long
and you confide and you confided in ms
hall right about some things yes she was
my friend you called her your chosen
sister
ms enriquez you claim to have seen signs
of injuries on your sister during the
course of her relationship with mr
depprite yes
but you never witnessed any incidents
that result resulted in visible injuries
to your sister right
uh other than the staircase incident
i i witnessed that incident what are you
asking me exactly you never witnessed
any incidents that resulted in signs of
injury that you were concerned about
over the course of their relationship
other than the staircase incident i did
witness that
no at no other time when you know that
was the only time that i saw him
and you didn't see what caused any of
the injuries you claim to have seen
during the course of their relationship
right other than the staircase incident
yeah staircase incident is the only one
that i saw but you have seen your sister
land a blow on mr depp right that was
the time yes after he hit me
no further questions your honor all
right redirect i have no redirect all
right is this witness subject to recall
no see maybe is subject to recall
no
okay all right ma'am you are free to go
or you can stay in the courtroom it's up
to you okay thank you
all right our next witness your honor is
another deposition designation okay it's
going to be um
how long is it
this particular one is about 45 minutes
okay
all right well we go ahead and it's
early but when we go ahead and take our
afternoon recess though
um that way we get everything
ready uh for you so we'll just take our
15-minute break now and then we'll come
back and have that deposition okay so
we'll see in 15 minutes don't do any
outside research don't talk to anybody
so that's 45 minutes and what do you
have another uh yes then we have another
one so we have a deposition a few more
okay so they're both depositions yes
yeah all the rest of them today are
deposition different okay i just want to
make sure we don't need any uh other
items from that okay that's fine we'll
come back at 305 then okay
all right are we ready for the jury yes
all right thank you
so
all right thank you you seated all right
your next witness
our next witness your honor is elizabeth
mars mars m-a-r-s m-a-r-z m-a-r-z thank
you
all right
please state your full name for the
record
elizabeth ray mars between the time that
you lived in new york so let's say 2007
2008 through 2015-16
how many times would you estimate that
you saw it's heard
i don't remember
more than four times
um
no
in 2015 and 16 do you recall how close
you and ms pennington were as friends
yeah we were pretty close um
[Music]
pretty close
in your previous testimony i'll
represent to you ms mars that you
testified that in at least in july of
2016 you would communicate with miss
pennington weekly i don't remember maybe
at that time perhaps we were
communicating like i said there were
moments where we were communicating
weekly or daily agree with me that you
would remember something as significant
as one of your girlfriends telling you
somebody you've known since
texas when you were young girls
you would remember if miss heard told
you that her husband or fiance or
boyfriend was
beating her
exactly remember that
correct and your testimony is that you
only lived at the eastern columbia
building in february of 2016 for two
weeks
it was around two weeks i don't know the
specific amount of time but it was
definitely
a little over two weeks less than a
month
um and
yes
and when you stayed at the eastern
columbia building did you stay in one of
the penthouses
yes okay and did you understand that
that penthouse was owned by mr depp
at the time
i assumed it was yes
and for what purpose did you go to the
eastern columbia building on may 21 2016
to assist raquel and
getting ready for a bead show that she
was going to be doing the following day
did you ever see mr depp
be violent towards anyone
i experienced him that night as
like i was personally i was scared of
him
so that's all i can say from the moment
that the one interaction i had with him
that night it was
frightening to me
his behavior was frightening to me
no she wouldn't wear makeup i mean
i didn't i don't think of her as someone
who wears a lot of makeup
no
yeah you've known her a long time right
she's never been somebody that wears a
lot of makeup correctly exactly unless
she's going to something that she needs
to put makeup on
right but other than that she's usually
bare-faced and beautiful yeah
so it's your recollection your best
recollection that miss pennington was
with you in penthouse 5
and never left with miss heard
before mr depp arrived is that correct
correct
so you hear some type of commotion you
don't know where it's coming from
correct
it sounds like yeah i mean it sounds
like it's coming from
it i hear we hear commotion and then it
feels like it's getting closer and
closer and closer
did it sound like
voices or did it sound
like destruction
it sounded like voices and destruction
that the door was abruptly opened
correct abruptly open
okay so you hear the commotion it feels
like it's getting closer and closer what
happened next
then you know soon after the door
slammed open and johnny came like
bursting through the door who opened the
door
johnny okay was johnny alone
there's the two men behind him okay
following him so johnny opens the door
he's got his two
what we'll assume are his bodyguards
with him
what happens next
so it all happened very fast he
basically the door kind of burst open
and he came in very just from my
perspective
really under the influence of something
drugs or alcohol because he was
very
sloppily like
he looked wasted
he was holding a very large bottle of
wine looked like some sort of like a
magnum bottle of wine which was kind of
spilling all over the place
and as he opened the door
he just what i remember what he mumbled
was get your [ __ ] out of here
and i just remember it all happened very
fast like the door slamming him saying
get your [ __ ] out of here the wine
that whole
you know his way his whole
being
really frightened me it almost felt like
he was coming towards me from my
perspective
whether he was coming towards me or not
it scared me and i just
ran out past him
you said mr depp appeared to be
either drunk or high is that correct he
was seemed to be intoxicated
okay
is that different than drunk
um no i mean yeah i guess
yeah he definitely seemed like he was
under the influence of something
and on may 21st 2016
how is mr depp's demeanor different
he was
it was much more sloppy and all over the
place and frightening and
um
yeah combative
you know felt very
angry he felt angry
and
yeah
and when you say combative what was
combative specifically about his
demeanor
just the way he burst through the room
just very forcefully
and rushed in very quickly to the point
that it made me want to get past him and
run out very quickly like it wasn't an
invite it was
it was very
yeah it was intense
okay
so mr depp
comes through the door
to penthouse five
and you
hear him say something to the effect of
get your [ __ ] out of here
correct
and then you ran out immediately
thereafter yes did you see mr depp
spill any wine
in penthouse 5 before you ran out
yes
how much wine did you see him spill
i don't remember
a lot the entire bottle
not the entire bottle
what might so what i remember was it was
flailing and it was there was definitely
wine that was
coming out
would you say that
being sloppy is different than being
combative
um
yeah i would say sloppy and combative
are two different
things and it's your testimony that mr
depp was on may 21st 2016 both combative
and sloppy correct
yeah i would describe it that there was
a little bit of both of yes but
combative and
sloppy was he more sloppy than he was
combative it felt more combative than
sloppy
and just to clarify the only thing that
was combative was
the words he was speaking
no it was completely the way he entered
into the room
rushed in his energy
the way it felt like he was coming after
me like he almost felt like from my
where i was standing it felt like he was
charging towards me and i was scared and
it was
um it felt
um
it felt yeah combative it felt
i'm trying to look for another word that
can describe what i felt but it was
you know it was scary my heart was
beating really fast very quickly and i
was
freaked out
okay so after you exchanged some text
messages with miss pennington you came
out of your hiding spot
and then went to
with pennington and mr drew's penthouse
is that correct
correct
so who was in penthouse one
when you got out of the hiding spot and
came to penthouse i mean
it was josh raquel amber and i were the
people that were at some point in there
during that time
okay
remember the first time you saw miss
heard after this incident
i remember seeing her after that
incident it was in
that apartment penthouse one correct so
the first time you saw miss heard after
this incident
on may 21 2016 was in penthouse one
what do you recall seeing the first
thing you saw when you saw ms heard
um i just remember she looked really
upset and disheveled and her hair was a
mess and
she had a swollen face
red she had a red swollen face okay have
you ever seen ms heard cry before may 21
2016.
i don't think so
not that i can remember
okay
what side of her face was swollen
i think it was her right side of her
face
do you have an independent recollection
that is the right side of her face
that was swollen
i'm taking myself back there and trying
to remember like where i was standing
versus you know what i mean i think it
was yeah i think looking at her
it was on my left and her right side
okay so let's talk about her hair seemed
disheveled so you said her hair was
disheveled
was she crying
yeah there was definitely tears
she animated
yeah she was visibly really upset
okay so visibly very upset
means what she was crying
okay
and what else
uh tears sadness felt like confusion
um felt like
those were the main
things would you describe
what did mr drew say if anything
i don't remember
him saying what he said
i think everybody was just
shaken up
so soon after you went into penthouse
one you remember some police officers
coming i remember yeah i remember there
was police officers in the hallway
was miss herd icing her face
after the incident but before the police
arrived
i think so who gave her the ice
i don't remember
so you were in penthouse one when the
police came
um how do you know that they
came
what did you hear what did you see
um because
they said the police are here so
i don't
remember again this is a very long time
ago so specific details are going to be
really hard for me to remember i just
know knowing that police were there in
the hallway two of them and in february
when you lived at the penthouse
for a few weeks
you didn't hear or see
any abuse by mr depp towards miss
correct
correct
and
did you go to amber and
johnny's penthouse
thereafter or where did you go next
so i just remember at some point ending
up yes at some point we were in
their penthouse afterwards in johnny and
amber's at some point we went over there
and did you go over there you think
after the police came
it was after the first two police
officers came okay do you remember
glass
on the floor at this point i don't
remember what i saw i don't remember if
it was cleaned up by the time i got
there or
if there was glass on the floor when i
walked in do you recall seeing wine
spilled
i recall
seeing wine spilled in the hallway
like a lot of wine spilled in the
hallway when do you recall seeing the
wine spilled in the hallway
at some point in the night maybe after
you know before
[Music]
uh
i i recall i mean i don't remember
specifically but i remember seeing wines
built in the hallway remember that being
one of the things that i saw that was
part of the
destruction of whatever what happened
okay so the police come
and you stayed in penthouse
one correct okay it was after the police
officers left that you
went to penthouse three correct where
amber and johnny lived correct recall
seeing wine spelled in the hallway i
remember seeing wines fall in the
hallway yeah okay and you saw the wine
after the police officers came correct
i think so didn't miss pennington take
any photographs of the scene
i remember raquel taking photographs of
amber's face
and now going to your description of
miss herd's face you said it was the
right side of her face
you said it was what swollen
and red
what else correct
um yeah it was swollen and red
was any part of her face more swollen
than others
it was around her eye
had bruising developed already
no it was red and swollen
so you did not see any bruising on this
herd's face
the evening of may 21st 2016. correct i
saw a red swollen
puffy
face okay and just
on the right side correct
correct
but it wasn't your testimony ms mars
that you were inside
penthouse one when the first police
officers came
exact correct
and how much time do you estimate they
spent
in the penthouses
i don't remember
the second group of officers there was
two sets of officers that came the
second set of officers that i actually
um
was in the apartment in
ph three i think it was did you hear
about
either
ms heard
mr drew or miss pennington cleaning
anything
that mr depp allegedly
destroyed
i don't remember but i'm i i do remember
that
i'm pretty sure that josh was
helping to clean up
before i got into the i remember that
knowing that the place was cleaned up
before i entered in there
before you entered into where into the
main apartment so you recall
josh drew cleaning up
before
you entered penthouse
three
what was he cleaning up exactly i just
remember by the time that i got gotten
into that apartment that someone had
cleaned up
the glass and the line that had been
that was on the floor
recall who told you that penthouse 3 had
been cleaned up
i don't no one specifically told me it
was i'm what i was expressing is that it
was cleaned up before i got there for
the most part i just remember that for
the most part from what i don't remember
to clarify mars when you came into
penthouse 3
after the police officers the first set
of police officers came and left
you did not see
silver candlesticks candelabra sticks
broken on the floor baskets of fruit
that had been on the kitchen island
fruit everywhere baskets on the ground
containers holding the spoons and forks
kitchen utensils spilled
a lamp a little statue thing
broken
in penthouse
five
i'm sorry penthouse three
now that i'm reading this i'm sort of
remembering that there was like some
stuff that had like something that had
been broken like a little stacked like
the statue thing kind of sounds familiar
to me now that i'm reading this but
again i don't remember when i walked in
if there was
if and i don't remember this being on
the on the floor i don't remember seeing
okay so you don't remember seeing it
yeah i don't remember seeing it i don't
remember but again as i'm reading this
stat when i see the statue i kind of
there's something that's like oh maybe
yeah i feel like i remember there was
some
something that was some things that were
broken but i don't specifically remember
what they were you did not witness i
didn't firsthand anything i didn't win i
didn't witness firsthand johnny
abusing amber but
do you recall testifying to that effect
that johnny charged at you and that you
were scared he charged towards me and i
was scared i ran past him
you didn't run past him because he told
everyone in that penthouse to get out of
his penthouse i ran past him for
because he was
because he ran into the unit
and it scared the [ __ ] out of me because
he was wasted and screaming
so
that's why i ran out
if there's a grown-ass man coming at you
and saying get your [ __ ] out of here
and swing a magnum-sized
bottle of wine
i'm sure
i don't know what anyone do i can't say
what anyone do but i ran out and will
you just remind us what side of miss
hurt's face you recall the marks being
on on may 21st 2016
the right side of her face do you feel
indebted to miss herd in any
no
have you ever done miss hertz makeup
no you testified earlier today that um
misheard often in the times you saw her
would not be wearing makeup is that
correct
correct is it possible in some of those
times that she was wearing the type of
makeup we
ladies sometimes use to
not appear as though we're wearing
makeup
yeah
so you wouldn't necessarily be able to
tell whether or not she was wearing
basic concealer or foundation correct
uh talking about the loud noises what
did you hear yeah just um screaming
yelling
um door slamming
commotion
could you tell whether the screaming and
the yelling was a male voice or a female
voice
from what i can remember male 1
and could you tell where the
screaming and the yelling was coming
from
i mean it felt like it was coming
started
farther down the hallway and then it was
coming
like closer so essentially i mean i
don't know but it could have been the
hallway
and so after you start hearing the
screaming and the yelling and the door
slamming and the commotion you testify
that mr drew got up and went to the door
yeah what what did mr drew do
he was
kind of pacing by the door
um and looking through the peephole
and what happened next
and then the door
like burst open and johnny came
charging in
and
screamed
again holding the magnum size bottle of
wine
you know flailing it around looked
intoxicated
kind of stumbling and
screamed get your [ __ ] out of here as
he
ran in my direction
and i
[Music]
was scared it was very it was very
frightening and
you know just scary and unexpected and
so i just darted out past him and ran up
towards the pool gym area and hid there
prior to the night of may 21 2016
had
a man ever charged at you holding a
magnum bottle of wine screaming
profanities
objection and what was your reaction to
this event when it happened on may 21
2016.
in fear
besides
the screaming and the door slamming
and the wine
waving do you recall anything else about
mr depp's actions that evening during
that moment i guess i should say
this is a rad i would describe it as
erratic behavior
was was anyone else with mr depp when he
charged into penthouse five
behind him were two men
what about miss heard
no
what about miss pennington
no
so you testified that
after a mistake mr deb burst into the
apartment and started charging towards
you that you
darted out and hid and i believe it's a
communal exercise area is that correct
yeah i darted out and went up the stairs
and
hid somewhere over by there
why did you hide
because i was
sorry say again why did you hide because
i was scared
what were you scared of
i just didn't know what he would do i
didn't i didn't
i didn't know what he would do
and the he there is who johnny
what were you thinking when you were
hiding
in the communal exercise area
i don't remember just
that i was i mean i just remember being
scared
and not wanting to leave that area until
like i
was clear that there was
that i wasn't going to be attacked
and at some point did you leave the area
yes
and what prompted you to leave the area
uh a text with raquel just telling her
to come to
her and josh's apartment
and did you do as ms pennington said and
go to her and josh's apartment yes
sitting here today do you remember what
you were thinking as you were sort of
coming out of your hiding spot and
walking towards
the penthouses again
i think
i think the whole thing was just bizarre
like really frightening and bizarre to
me i don't
i don't specifically remember what i was
thinking other than like
holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] just happened you know um
and
is he gone
maybe i was thinking that i don't
remember specifically
and when you say is he gone who's the
heat you're referring to there
johnny
when you got to miss pennington's and mr
drew's penthouse
um who'd you see who was there
i don't remember who was specifically
there when i first walked in but
throughout
the time being in there in that moment
definitely
amber raquel and
josh
and maybe like just by peeping into the
hallway one of the police officers
when you saw miss heard after you came
back down from your hiding spot and
you're in mr drew's and miss
pennington's apartment how did she look
she looked
frazzled and just completely
disheveled her hair was
all over the place she had
a swollen face
looked like she had been crying
and
yeah
do you think the swollen face was a
result of her having been crying
no what do you think it was a result of
it looked like she'd been like hit in
some way like it was definitely it was
not from crying and she had
markings on her face
were the marks that she saw in miss
hurt's face after you came down from
your hiding spot present when you had
been hanging out with her earlier in the
day
no
you testified earlier today that you
witnessed some i believe it was mr penny
miss pennington or mr drew
take some photos of miss heard's face do
you remember that
yes
i'd like to mark what will be mars
exhibit 13.
miss mars as the court reporter hands
you
exhibit 13 and i'll represent to you
that these were some photos taken on the
night of may 21st 2016. so if you turn
to the second photo in the set do you
recognize the person in this photograph
yes who is it amber
and do you see any marks on her face in
this photograph
yes and do these marks look like the
marks that you saw in person on her face
on the evening of march 21 2016
yes
and just to clarify these marks were not
on her face when you saw miss heard
earlier that same afternoon and we're
helping miss pennington make beads
correct
there are other photos in this set um
why don't we turn back to the first one
some broken frames on a bed do you know
what this picture is of
uh yeah i mean this is amber and
johnny's
bed
and there's bro there's photographs on
it so i take it that you've seen amber
and johnny's bedroom before
yes
do you recall whether you went into mr
jepson miss heard's bedroom that night
no
no you don't recall or no you didn't no
i
don't recall um the next photo in the
set is the picture of miss heard
just after that there's a photo you're
with me
of what appears to be a a hallway are
you with me yes do you recognize what
this is an image of yes what is it an
image of
it's the hallway between all the
penthouse apartments
so you've been on this hallway many
times
yes uh do you see the sort of red
staining on the right hand corner of the
page
yes um
do you recall seeing that red staining
the night of may 21 2016 yes and what
was it
it was wine so you saw that staining on
the night of may 21 2016.
yes do you recall whether it was there
when you arrived in the afternoon
i don't remember seeing it now so when
was the first time you remember seeing
it
um i think when i came out of my hiding
spot and came downstairs
i'm back into raquel and josh's
apartment
but you didn't see the wine get spilled
not this snow
you saw other wine get spilled
i saw yeah as he was and when he came in
the apartment with when he was flailing
the line
and the he there is johnny then the last
photo in this set appears to be of some
picture frames hanging on a wall do you
see that yes i think it's an amber and
johnny's apartment i think but again
i don't remember if it's in her studio i
don't know do you recall seeing this
photo in one of the penthouses before
yes
and when you saw it was it broken no
and what if anything do you remember
about miss pennington's state
also
distraught
upset
you've been friends with state energy
just
trying to
be supportive to amber and to raquel and
just really
trying to be like the man in the
situation that was gonna like really
be grounded amongst like women that were
sort of like frightened and sort of
a little more frantic he was very
grounded and very like clear and
i remember like feeling safe and like he
was it was like protection you testified
earlier today that quote there are some
things that i really remember and some
things that are a little shady end quote
which bucket do the marks that you saw
on this hurts face on the evening of may
21 2016 fall into the things that were
a little shady are the things that you
really remember
that i really remember
all right your next witness
witness your honor is melanie in glacis
and that is also by video and i will say
that that begins with ms vasquez
questioning first and then then i come
back all right and if you spell it last
name just for the course i n g l e s s i
s thank you
please state your name and address for
the record
my name is melanie glycis and missing
glaciers that's me first i'm a makeup
artist
and you in fact are a professional
makeup artist correct correct when did
you first meet amber hurd
april
2015 and what was the occasion
tribeca film festival in new york
and were you providing makeup services
for her on that occasion
correct
okay
and did you become friends with amber
heard after that
i did
missing glaciers i'm going to show you
what has been marked as
exhibit number seven do you recognize
what's depicted in this photograph
yes
i recall seeing this um on the kitchen
of the penthouse when you enter
that's the other bar kitchen it to the
left and that was there
yes
but when you came to the penthouse after
uh after amber had texted you
whether it was that night or the next
day
you saw this in the kitchen is that
correct painted lack of foundation and
so you do recall being there that that
evening i do recall being there
you know my
my only concern with all of this is that
the day before or during another
incident
but
it says
if my text said i was dead the night
before then i was there the night before
mrs iglesias i'm going to ask you to
look at what has been marked as
deposition exhibit number nine
do you recognize
what is depicted in this photo
well it's a bed it looks like i mean
it's a very tight picture of the bed but
i must
i mean
the bed
and do you recall seeing this the night
of december 15 with the broken part of
the bed
upstairs yes
okay
and when you say upstairs what do you
mean
well
the bedroom was upstairs and the
downstairs had the kitchen with the
writing do you remember where the
other property that you saw
was was that downstairs or upstairs the
property that was damaged was that
upstairs or downstairs downstairs
all right just so i'm clear you recall
damage to the bed is that correct
and asked an answer on december 16 2015
did you return to amber heard's
penthouse
yes and
why did you come to amber heard's
penthouse on december 16
it was the james corden show she had an
appearance so i went back in back to
work and
when you arrived at the penthouse on
december 16
please describe for me
what you observed about ever heard space
and
any injuries when i
came to the penthouse on december 16 to
do
amber's makeup
she had injuries
um
she had
two light
like i don't know how i don't know i
mean i'm not a medical expert i don't
know how i would describe them but
it could have looked like somebody had
headbutted her lightly so she had a
discoloration here under both eyes and
on the bridge of the bridge of the nose
uh and she had
what i would call a split lip or
something on the lip like a gash or a
split lip
is in glaciers i'm going to ask you to
look at what has been marked as exhibit
number 11.
do you
recognize this photo as being amber
heard's head
yes
okay and could you please describe for
me what what this photo is is uh
showing
it's showing a chunk of missing hair
and
what if anything did you observe on
december 16 about amber heard missing a
chunk of hair
i remember this because
she showed it to us
and
i looked at it
okay and can you describe
uh
what is depicted right along her scalp
there
i don't know
do you recall that there was some
bruising along the scalp and some pus
for lack of a better word
i don't recall
ms iglesias i'm going to ask you to take
a look at
what has been marked as exhibit number
14 do you recognize the person in this
photo
yes
and who is that
this is amber hood okay and
were they you you just described what
you saw on the 16th with respect to
amber heard's
injuries does this accurately depict
what you saw on amber heard on december
16 2015 yes
ms iglesias i'm going to ask you to take
a look at what has been marked as
exhibit 16.
again do you recognize the person in
this photo
yes
and who is that
neighborhood okay and does this picture
reflect the injuries that you saw on
amber heard on december 16 2015 yes
okay
and then i'm going to ask you to take a
look at one more of those and that is uh
exhibit 17.
and i'm going to ask again mr glacias do
you recognize the person in this picture
and maybe to try to move it along is it
amber heard
yes okay and does this uh
reflect what you saw
as well on december 16 2015. i mean
there's three different three pictures
with very different lights but yes now
do you also recall there being an injury
to amber
amber heard's lip
correct and miss and glaciers i'm going
to ask you to take a look at exhibit
number 19 and do you recognize the
person in this
photograph as amber heard
yes
and does this picture accurately reflect
uh what you saw
on amber heard on december 16 2015. yes
mrs could you please describe
what you did by way of makeup to prepare
amber heard for the james corden show on
december
16 2015.
yes uh we covered
you know i just did makeup but just a
little heavier weight knitted so we
covered
you know the the discoloration the
bruises
with a little slightly heavier concealer
one that has a little more of a peach
undertone
which i would normally don't use on
amber but peach do cancel blue so i did
that under the eyes and i
although amber always you know has a red
lip is one of the signature look i
remember clearly talking that we had no
other option that night but then to use
a red blood like a really red lipstick
to
you know make sure we could cover up
the injuries on the lip
and
were you able to cover all of the
injuries with the makeup that you
applied and as you just described yes
ms iglesias if you could look at what
has been marked as exhibit number 22 do
you recognize
uh amber heard in that picture
yes
okay and
was
is this the picture of her is this
picture of her
that evening december 16 2015 on the
james corden show
yes
what if anything did you observe on the
difference in amber herds demeanor
before the show and then on the show
that she had the ability to you know
turn it on that she
you know the ability to do her job and
and perform how she was supposed to
perform on the show
and
prior to amber
going on the show and while you were
working with her on her makeup
how would you describe amber's
mood and demeanor
angry
sad
a little erratic
um i think through ways of emotions you
know
do you recall
someone named miss macmillan having
any role in in helping to prepare amber
heard for that james corden show that
night december 16
yes
what do you recall
someone thought
samantha was a stylist samantha was
there
um the day of the gem squadron show as
she was always there to get her ready
before an appearance her show
and did samantha work on
amber before or after you were applying
the makeup
i don't know if she worked
on amber uh but when i entered the
penthouse five
samantha was there with amber so
samantha was there before i entered the
house the penthouse
and
do you recall whether
samantha was hugging amber when you came
in i recall
i recall
opening the penthouse
so there's two panaceas there's the
penthouse
where she gets ready so amber the
penthouse where samantha gets already
where olympus closes if i recall
properly does depend us that i enter
first just to say hi before i would go
set up in the other penthouse and my
recollection is to when i
amber was crying
looked pretty upset
on some mental shoulder or they were
like you know
madeline hugging is the right way but
they were definitely had a a moment
where um they were together
and amber looked really upset
mr glaciers i i'm gonna ask you just a
couple more questions about the makeup
um that you applied
on amber on december 16 2015 for the
james corden show i i think you said
that you had applied some concealer
and that you had some peach undertones
with it to cancel out some blue did i
hear that correctly
i was asking about i i wrote down that
you said that you had applied
on amber concealer you had some peach
undertones to cancel
blue
is that what you said
so what type of concealer
did you apply to amber
and if you use different color tones can
you please describe why you use the
color tones you did i used a different
kind of concealer that i would normally
use on amber which i used a concealer
that had peach undertone peach on the
tone concealer
are more effective to cover any darkness
or a blue undertone that a normal
concealer
do you know what type of makeup amber
heard typically wore
objection david can you please describe
for me
yes uh she's pretty natural she has a
concealer
um
from a company called she used to have a
concealer from a company called clitter
pool
um
her makeup would be pretty simple
concealer and a little um benefit tint
that she used on her lips and she used
on her cheeks
very natural it had a natural look to it
correct
correct
okay um but there was she did wear
concealer and what you described correct
do you mean in her daily life or that
night
in her daily life
yes she used she has a concealer that
she use all the time
and those cup she has a couple of
products that she uses all the time
daily yes
well i mean daily yes
as far as i know and and do you feel
confident in what you described
uh that you saw that day of amber hurd's
injuries and i'm talking about december
16
2015
a thousand percent that a doubt
because i just don't remember
you know it's five years ago i don't
remember the exact date and could you
describe
uh amber heard's demeanor
in that
in that those days before and after the
filing for divorce and for the domestic
violence restraining order an er
an area of different of emotion you know
from
i mean definitely from sadness to
not wanting to divorce to divorce to
anger to
raise to be really upset to be really
sad so it's just it was just a roller
coaster of emotion
that
i think we were all there those couple
of days to help navigate and and and go
through it
i i take it from your response today you
still feel very emotional about this
it's very difficult for you isn't it
it's not difficult for me no now no but
it just reminded me of the time how i
felt yes
when did you first tell miss heard that
you
were no longer interested in
having her as a client and being friends
with her
at that point
about a month ago
how was it that
well i just told amber that you know i
wish her well i not just just to have no
interest in continuing
a relationship whatever it's work-wise
or uh friendship-wise
but is there a specific reason
other than
the birth of your child and the
postpartum issues that you described
with this client and
missing glaciers
what was your impression of mr deb when
you first met him
lovely
you thought he was lovely yeah
was each of the
well let me ask the backup question
did you interact with mr depp how many
times did you interact with mr dub
through
you mean
all in all well yes the entirety of your
interactions how many were there
approximately
five maybe
maybe
maybe less than ten
maybe yeah
and would you describe all your
interactions with mr death as quote
lovely yes
did you ever see mr deb
act in a violent manner
no
did you ever see mr death
yell at misheard
no
did you ever see him kick misheard
no do you ever see mr death throw an
object at misheard
no
did you ever see mr dab slap miss hurt
no
punch her
no
did you ever see mr dad kick miss hurd
no
is it fair to say missing glaciers that
you never saw mr duck be physically
abusive towards misheard
correct
and you never saw mr deck cause any
injuries she must hurt correct
did i ever saw him causing any injuries
no
and so any injuries that you claim to
have seen on this herd you don't know
one way or another how they were caused
correct correct
the only source of information that you
have
is miss heard's own words correct
correct
did you hear mr depp
and miss heard having a fight on the
phone i was there i was present in the
room and but just to confirm
could you hear mr depp's voice
no
so fair to say that the only voice you
heard was with
was miss hurts correct
correct
and so you don't know what she what mr
depp said to ms heard
on that phone call correct
correct
do you recall any other
occasions where you witnessed
a fight between mr depp and miss heard
or heard about an incident or a fight
between mr depp and miss heard other
than the three that we've now discussed
i would say
every time
i would say that during
my friendship with amber before she
passed for divorce which i mean timeline
i don't know a year maybe a year and a
half it was all it was always
it was always
some conflict
some fight some
some physical fights some verbal fights
some kind of problems some kind of
there's always it's always was a problem
a problematic it was a very consuming
um
for
me
it was all consuming about that
relationship it was a very consuming
friendship enhanced that's why i decided
not to
continue it
but you yourself missing like this
didn't witness any of these altercations
fights arguments correct between mr d i
think you testified that you interacted
with mr death
less than 10 times
when you did interact with mr death
was misheard present
each of those times
all of those times
did you find him particularly loving
towards misheard
and during these interactions with mr
depp and miss heard
at that time you were aware that mr depp
allegedly was abusing this herd correct
well most of
most of the interaction that i had was
towards the end of
2015
right i'm assuming so i was not fully
aware yet
of
i guess the the um
the seriousness of of of um
the fight if i can say so i think um you
know
most of the time i saw them together was
towards the end of december towards
before december 15. so thanksgiving
that time and amber's i think birthday
i'm getting to do that so
the few times that i saw mr deb
was before
i understood
the seriousness of this fight
understanding again came from miss heard
only correct well miss heard and
some of her friend
yes
who were some of her friends
rocky
retro pennington um
io
twilight um i'm not sure you pronounce
it
josh drew the people that were leaving
her sister
whitney
those were the cool groups
you said you spent thanksgiving with uh
mr duff and miss heard was that in
thanksgiving november 2015
yes correct because they were divorced
by may 2016 yes
how would you describe that evening
awkward
why
because marilyn manson was there
did you know marilyn manson
no
but this was an awkward thanksgiving
sitting there it was quite intimate
so sitting yeah it was just awkward
isn't awkward
isn't it he's just an awkward being and
it's just awkward to be around
it was an awkward evening do you recall
mr death and miss heard having any type
of
disagreement or fight
that evening
um
this agreement may be
like yeah lack of disagreement what do
you mean by that
well i mean there was you know you it
was such a small intimate
surrounding that you pick up on things
um and so i could tell that it was it
was awkward
it was just awkward i think mr depp and
and
mr manson disappeared for a while and
everybody was at the table so they was
wondering why they were just awkward and
you're pretty sure they had a fight
because miss heard told you after the
fact that they had a fight correct
because you were you did not witness mr
depp or missed her having any type of
fight the evening of thanksgiving
correct correct
missing glaciers
do you have an independent recollection
of going to the penthouse in downtown
los
angeles on december 15 2015. i have an
independent
i have
an independent
recollection of going to the penthouse
before one of the incident
and
at the time i wasn't i couldn't recall
if it was
the day before the jam squadron
or the day before the fun incident
you know so
what and that is what i made sure i
needed to remember that it was the day
before december 16th
where yes
does that make sense so i i knew i had
come a day before
a day
before one of the two
biggest fights that you know and i
wasn't sure if it was that day or that
day but it was december 15th
and sitting here today you're still not
sure if you went to the penthouse on
december 15 2015 or if it was the day
before the may incident in 2016.
and when you went to the penthouse on
december 15th i believe you testified
before that you didn't see any injuries
on amber heard that evening correct
sorry i don't recall seeing any injuries
on amber that day
that night
do you recall miss pennington was at the
penthouse that evening
yes
do you recall if anybody else was at the
penthouse that evening
but you do remember miss heard being
there and miss pennington correct right
right
did you take any photographs of miss
heard the evening of december 15 2016
no
do you recall being present when any
photographs of ms heard were taken on
december 15 2015
i don't recall
do you remember being present when
photographs of miss heard's injuries
were taken on december 16 2006 2015.
no
and did you take any pictures
of miss heard and her injuries on
december 16 2015. no
so i don't want to take up the time of
showing you all the photographs misheard
or excuse me miss bredenhoff showed you
earlier today but
there were a number of exhibits
i think i marked them as
exhibits
14 through 20.
they were shown earlier this morning
just to confirm you didn't take any of
those photographs correct not on my
phone not with my phone and i do not
recall
taking ambrose or rocky's phone to take
those pictures no definitely with my
phone
i do not recall taking physically myself
picture no i don't recall
would it be normal for miss her to have
makeup on her face before you arrive to
do her makeup ahead of an appearance it
would be normal for amber to have
concealer on a little
a little of that tin there yes because
it is quite normal for amber to wash
your face you always like to wash the
face before the makeup with the product
that she likes do a toner
you know so it wouldn't be abnormal for
her to have a little makeup before and
then wash her face and start clean
but you don't remember one way or
another whether miss heard had a fresh
face with toner and moisturizer on
before when you arrived on december 16
2015. correct
no i do not i don't recall
would she usually wash her face and go
through that process in front of you
yes i mean in front of me uh
in her bathroom but you know we we were
close so it wouldn't be abnormal for me
to be chit chatting with her while she'd
clean her face and
you know i don't think specifically in
front of me or not in front of me but
yeah i mean she would wash her face in
the bathroom which is adjacent to where
we get her ready
and i want to be really specific so
based on your best recollection
what injuries did you see on this herd
on december
16 2015
amber had a slight
discoloration on both eyes and on the
top of the bridge of the nose
and
hold on uh and i do believe the right
eye adds a little more of the gash right
there it was it wasn't that strong it
wasn't that swollen but it was
definitely some blue and yellow
discoloration there mainly on the inner
corner
and a little more here and then she had
on the right
on the right lip as i said earlier i
went to the exact medical term but it
looked like a split lip or like a gash
here
did you ever seen this herd's lip bleed
um on december 15 or december 16th
but you have a you you remember that it
was not bleeding on december 16th when
you were applying the makeup correct
when i was applying the makeup correct
how about before you were applying the
makeup do you recall it bleeding
and i think you described it as either a
gash or a split lip
i don't know what would be the medical
term for it i don't know what kind of
injury would have caused this i'm not a
medical expert nor forensic expert but
it was slightly swollen and by the way
you can see it in that video so it's
crazy to me but it was slightly swollen
and there was
either a gash or a
no not a scab
it was swollen with some kind of cut
do you recall miss heard ever having a
cold sore on her lips
no
you said there was slight discoloration
under both eyes was there swelling under
both eyes as well
clarify swelling um
maybe
very little but it was mainly
discoloration at two i recall mainly
uh
discoloration like a
like a bruise
maybe there was a little tiny swelling
on one of the eye
that was a little more
a little more injured than the other but
not huge swelling though i believe your
testimony earlier today was that he
lightly headbutted her is that correct
i i wasn't there i don't know if you
liked you're not like here
that was that was your testimony that it
appeared as if she had been quote
lightly head-butted do you remember
saying that earlier today
it's not my position to say
how head-butted she wasn't or anything
and maybe i'm misquoted
okay and did she show you
the hair that was missing she show us
me and the hairdresser the
where the hair was missing on top of the
head
and was miss macmillan there as well
no miss ma samantha magnet was
really never when we get ready so it was
two separate things
and samantha never really comes up when
we get ready now but just to confirm
these injuries right that you saw on
this hurt on december 16 2015
you don't know
how they were caused
correct correct
and so any information you have about
how the cause of these injuries came
from this heard only
from december 16 correct
well any injuries other than ms hurd and
her friends you never witnessed mr depp
being violent or abusive towards
misheard and causing any injuries
correct
so let's talk about the makeup that you
actually used to conceal these injuries
on her face on december 16th
i believe you testified you used a
concealer with a peach undertone
did you have training and experience
dealing with injuries or covering up
bruising on people do you have any
specific experience for education
specific experience i have experience in
doing bruises and cover bruises for
special effect
yeah i mean throughout my career i have
created bruises and i also have covered
bruises
for you know with models or
real life things whatever it is so yeah
i
i have experience in covering some
bruises yes
how about swelling same question
i mean it's really it's a little harder
to cover swelling
that would be maybe you know
try to bring the swelling down covering
covering it up would be not pretty would
be harder
and how about cuts
yeah
specifically as it relates to ms heard's
makeup look on december 16th
do you recall what
foundation you used
the brand
you probably don't remember the brand
but do you recall the shade that you
used
how would i no it's five years ago
absolutely not
okay
but you do have a specific recollection
of using a peach undertone concealer
yes and i tell you why because amber
always had in her bag we have the same
concealer she has a concealer from a
brand called clearpool
and it's a specific
shade uh you know it's beige beige was
amber's color found her eyes period so
the day december 16
i did a news beige i use
there's another concealer that has a
little more peach in there and orange
it's it's called honey from the same
family and i use that instead
and i think i also use i have a wheel
that has is a bruised wheel that has
different colors and you pick up the
color to
gently touch up any
darkness did you make a different choice
for her overall look other than the
concealer as a result of the injuries
that you saw on her face on december
16th not a different choice but i
remember we specifically
you know
as you i know you read it before she we
we had a red lip it was not uncommon for
her we know she has a signature red lip
so it's not suddenly it was oh my gosh i
read it but i remember that day was
specifically
i specifically structure my makeup
there's a couple of things we do with
amber we do a smoky eye and a nude lip
or red lip and i remember specifically
thinking of my makeup about we needed to
highlight
there to try to
not to try to not draw attention there
and the reddit was our only option to
cover that red
cut that was there so that i remember
very specifically thinking that
we had to have a red lip
sharp brows and construct the makeup to
take away
from here so basically i mean it's not
going to be nothing to you guys but just
basically a lot of highlight up here to
kind of
not focus on this i remember talking
about it very clearly
and and
forgive my ignorance
but what did you do to cover up the cut
on the lip other than apply a red lip
a red lip
okay
a red lip uh it is swollen
i can see it in a video on the james
bond show so a lips was swollen it was
bigger on that side you can see it
there's nothing i can do about that but
i did we did a really dark red lip to
to match that red
gas should cut whatever that was there
do you recall miss heard being hindered
as a result of the injury on her lip and
when i say hindered i mean did she have
trouble
opening her mouth widely
or
you know did she complain about it
hurting or splitting open and bleeding
do you recall any of that
and again just to confirm on december 15
2015 you don't recall seeing any
injuries including a split lip on amber
bird correct correct
do you recall having any specific
conversation
with the hairstylist that was doing miss
heard's hair on december 16 2015 as it
related to the abuse that ms heard was
describing for you
yeah um yes we have we talked a bit
about it yes
what what do you recall about that
conversation i mean
you know i think everybody was a little
like
oh [ __ ] okay um
i think everybody was a little surprised
everybody was a little like not knowing
how to
move forward with it i mean
but we talked as i said when amber was
in the chair and as he was behind her
and i was in front of her i recall the
three of us having this conversation and
i recall ideas showing me the whole day
but just to confirm you don't know how
that chunk of hair was missing
from ms heard's head you don't know what
caused that chunk of hair to be missing
correct
i don't know it correct
you don't have any personal knowledge i
should say as to how that chunk of hair
came to be missing from her head well i
never i mean i
i did not witness it right
alex may i please have you
bring up depth nine
missing glaciers you've testified
previously
um that you see
watching the video clip right um you see
miss herds
you see the swollen lip and you see uh
bruising
yeah
i see i i've known that face i know that
face so well i've done it so many times
i can tell where the bruises are and i
can tell where the swollen lip is
correct
so miss iglesias do you mind please
identifying for me is this um
does this photograph accurately depict
misheard on the james corbin show on
december 16 2015.
yes
but can you describe for me where you
see bruising
on miss hurt's face well no i didn't say
i saw bruce but i saw the discoloration
i can see my makeup so i see the
discoloration
on the right eye just right under i see
that little dent there and also i mean
this is
a picture that is
you know taking
this is not a really accurate picture
she's sideways
the light is one way
you know but yeah the other these are
better pictures
that you can see
but
you give me the the mouth i will show
you but this other still picture when
you can see the slightly better or the
swollen lip so i mean i can see there's
better pictures where you can see that
side of her lip
is swollen
this here
and when you're you're pointing just to
for the record you're pointing to the to
the right side of miss heard's lip
correct
correct
okay
it's here nothing but it as i said
there's better pictures she's sideways
there's better pictures where you can
see what i feel you can see better but
it might be the same photograph
yeah she's still sideways
but this is your testimony that you
believe you can see swelling on the
right side of miss heard's lip
yes
okay
do you see any bruising or
concealed bruising
under her eyes well i mean i know i've
concealed those bruises so yeah so i can
see them because i know i did it but
so that's neither here or there but yeah
i mean i can see them just on their eyes
on the right eyes i can see the little
gash right there
and i can all that darkness right i mean
i don't have the mass anymore but all
that darkness right there that is not
eye shadow and that is neither dark
circle for not sleeping this is part of
the little
you know the injury is showing through
do you see any
discoloration or bruising on the bridge
of her nose
i do not no i must have done a great job
there
do you recall anything about miss hurt's
appearance
when you first encountered her in
coachella valley
no i don't recall
did you notice any injuries mom misheard
i don't recall
do you recall miss her discussing any
abuse that she had sustained the night
of her birthday on april 21st 2016 by mr
death
yes what do you recall about
that
i recall there was a fight there was
[Music]
i don't remember i don't i don't exactly
recall the fight i know they would fight
and there was some problem that's why
they were late coming back to
coachella's
i don't recall exactly what she told me
but there was some problem the night
before yes
but you don't remember seeing any
injuries on this herd
after
her birthday dinner in april of 2016.
correct
do you recall seeing any injuries on
this herd's face
at that dinner on may 24th 2016.
i don't recall
do you recall miss heard's general
demeanor at the dinner on may 24th 2016.
what i remember about that dinner is
that she was
ex and i tell you why i remember this
clearly because she was very distraught
and she was very
um
confused if she should file or not for
divorce
and she
was really sad and upset
and angry
and all of it and i remember that
because that night
i actually physically took her phone
so she should not
so that if johnny tried to
[Music]
if johnny tried to reach
reach out to her again she wouldn't have
a phone that night and she would go she
would go through the divorce tomorrow
the next day so i remember physically
having her phone
and when i dropped when i dropped them
back at the penthouse she said keep my
phone
so if you contact me i won't know i
won't cave and i will fight for divorce
tomorrow so i went home in my house with
her phone
and
that's why i remember that's what i
stick in my mouth and then the next
morning and you can see those texts she
said i need my phone
and then i had to drive to the penthouse
and give her her phone back and at the
time that day
i'm assuming she fought for divorce and
that day that the whole circus started
and you you believe that ms heard should
go through with the divorce correct
correct
and and that was based on what exactly
missing glaciers
on
what she told me on on on
her recollection of
marriage
i think you testified earlier
that amber's practice was to wear
concealer some foundation moisturizer
things of that nature um
was there do you have any recollection
that amber
strayed from that and did not wear
makeup during the week of may 21st 2016
no
do you have any recollection that week
of thinking oh my goodness amber heard
doesn't isn't wearing her makeup this
week no
so
do you know whether
amber heard
i took any steps to reduce her swelling
uh during this
in preparation for the james corden
uh show
yes she took anika
and uh we had an annika jail
let's just say i always i always have
anika jelly in my kit anyway
uh and she had anika jail
she put yeah she used anika gel
and some ice and what does annika gel do
with respect to swelling
i use anika jelly in my kit
to bring
any swelling any swelling area of my
clients face down and how does that
typically work what's your experience it
just brings us you know the uh the
swelling down uh i mean not drastically
but it does it helps
with the swelling a little bit
all right
yes your honor we have another video
okay if you could approach for a moment
let me just certainly
all right your next witness you're gonna
call christy sexton and this is by video
deposition as well
all right that'll be the last one for
the day thank you
preliminaries
queensland australia
i've been at that address since july
2017.
there was a transitionary period
i met my husband in december of 2015.
so
16 and 17 decisions on which country we
were going to move to and such so i did
not establish residency here until july
and then began all my paperwork
subsequently when we were married in
october
of 2017.
i take it from your last answer mr
sexton that australia was the lucky
winner
yes i'm an acting coach
when
i believe it was sometime in 2009
for how long
uh did you remain amber
primary or exclusive acting coach
um i don't know about exclusive
we don't have any sort of exclusivity
contracts she may work with other
coaches um
uh the last time we worked on a project
together would be aquaman so 2017.
i don't know about exclusive we don't
have any sort of exclusivity contracts
she may work with other coaches
the last time we worked on a project
together would be aquaman so 2017.
okay so the first movie or the first
tv series i should say
that you were working on uh as an acting
coach with amber was the playboy club
yes
yes
i take it from what you just described
that although the frequency varied
um it's fair to say is it not that you
saw
misheard many many many times
during the period between
2010
and 2017. oh yes
would it be fair to say that you saw
misheard during seven year period
um more than a hundred times
easily yes
and when you say easily do you think
it's also fair to say that you saw her
more than 200 times
absolutely yeah
um i'm gonna go up another hundred uh
same answer for 300 times
yeah
as i said when i would see her it would
be multiple times a week in preparation
for a project when's the last time
that you had a
session
with amber heard as her primary acting
coach
[Music]
during mid-2017 early period when she
looked on orange avenue how would you
describe
do you think ever heard as an actor
she was really focused on moving to the
next level of her career
and really stretching herself as an
actor
she which is why she started coaching so
much at that time and initially even
went to
classes
so she was really driven to do a lot of
work
um and kind of mine out everything that
we could from the text and go over
things
a lot
so she was very driven as an actor to um
i would say get to the next phase of her
career
looking at sexton
one refresher recollection as to when
that took place
that's the imdb page yes it was either
2011 or 2012. um
if it's saying that it came out in 2011
then the premiere would have been in
2011 so yeah
when was the next time you were called
seeing uh johnny or mr button
i would say sometime in the middle of
the following
so year in the middle of 2012 you think
yeah
where was that
uh at her house on orange i remember him
seeing him quite a bit
in the early period you're gonna focus
on the early game
did you have occasion to run into mr
death
at your coaching sessions with amber
later when she moved into sweetheart
avenue and then at the penthouse
yes i did see him often at both sweeter
and
the downtown house
and over that period of time did you
observe
changes in mr
jack's behavior
yeah
johnny became
i would say
much darker as time went on
he um
he was
like figuratively and literally he would
sit in dark rooms
um the art overall changed like
everything got much darker in the houses
with like heavy
um
it was always a little
i don't know what the art form would be
dark but um it just like literally
lighting would go down and big curtains
would be everywhere and he
became much less talkative as time went
on
um
we'd see less and less of him personally
i would hear him in the house but i
would see less and less of him
interaction-wise
um and when i did um
he wasn't very happy
what would you hear him say on those
occasions
at different points in time i heard
different things uh
sometimes it would just be him milling
around the house sometimes it would be
him having conversations with his team
bodyguards and stuff
or his friends that were over making
music at the sweets or location
sometimes it was him an amber fighting
like
i was in his home so i heard him quite a
bit
you said a couple of answers ago that
from time to time you would hear
mr death and ms hurt fighting
can you
again keeping in mind that it's a long
time ago can you can you describe
what you heard
i would say
i would just hear a lot of him yelling
his voice would carry through kind of
the halls of the house
um
and then
like some i remember one time in
specific that i could hear amber was
trying to get out of the room
and then the door shut again and then i
could just hear muffled yelling on his
part
at the beginning of their relationship
once
her has revealed to you that they were
in fact in a relationship
uh did she talk to you about mr deft's
struggles with drugs and alcohol
in the early parts of their relationship
she had said that he was sober
she was trying to support him in his
sobriety
um
and
then subsequently throughout the
relationship we would talk about his
breaks in sobriety
based on your work uh as ms hertz acting
coach primary acting coach
was it your understanding that mr hur mr
jeff had opinions about what role
ms heard should take there were a couple
of occasions where i actually heard
johnny say
why would you want to do that kind of
role my woman isn't going to play that
kind of role
stuff like that i heard a few times from
him
over the course of time other than
saying that he didn't hearing mr dexter
he didn't want his woman
playing a role playing
excuse me do you ever hear him use any
other language like that
um about
the kind of roles that ms
heard was being offered
to focus you in
me sex and i'm talking about the period
when uh amber and johnny were together
in a relationship
until you stop being her acting coach in
2017
and i'm focusing in on what you would
call hearing from mr depp
about what roles he thought mishra
should play
as i said
he would be sitting
he would initially when she lived in the
orange
location sometimes he would be nearby it
was a fairly small house um and he would
be nearby and kind of uh earshot so
there were times that he was kind of
just disparaging that's that's a shitty
role why would you do that that kind of
thing
but he wasn't
super negative then
later on um
as it went on he was very
vocal about the negative terms like i
said he called it a horror part or a
trash part
um
or a piece of [ __ ] um all sorts of
things like that generally pretty
negative if it was something he didn't
want her to do
did the
number of role
that ms heard audition for
change
during the time that she was involved
with mr
yes it did uh it was
decreasing as it went
um and there would be
stretches of time where she wasn't
auditioning at all or working on
anything at all during the time that mr
depp and mr were together did you
observe changes in their relationship
all the time
yeah early on there were incredibly
lovey-dovey and
passionate and
always
together in a positive way they were
very playful and friendly
um
and
then
i would see less and less of them
together and i would hear a lot of um
muffled arguments through the walls
um
and when i did see him
uh sometimes
the balance would shift it went from
being like
a normal couple to very tension filled
especially those last few months that
they were together
and
yeah
uh today uh was there a [ __ ] later on
the number of times that ms heard
was late for or cancelled sessions with
you change
as
her relationship with mr depp went on in
time
yeah
in as i said earlier uh amber was never
late when we worked in the studio um
and then as it went on i began having to
actually build in a cushion of an hour
around her appointment um it started out
just an extra 15 minutes here and there
because she'd be like coming downstairs
or
they'd be discussing or he had to talk
to her at that moment in time and
eventually as the relationship
progressed and the fighting got heavier
i would have to build in time because
she'd be sobbing at the beginning of
sessions and we couldn't work until we
got her together
um
yeah i ended up having to do a lot of
cushion time around her just so that
we could actually get something
accomplished because she was often very
upset
did you have occasion to observe new
turd cry naturally not asking um when
you had coaching sessions with her
during the time that she was together
romantically with
i would say the last year they were
together probably
80 90 of our sessions began with her
crying
um
that would be increasing as it went on
ironically she has a little difficulty
crying
acting wise
which a lot of us do
and so
yeah we would have to work when we were
doing it acting wise but it was a lot
towards the end there a lot of crying
sessions based on your testimony here
ms sexton is the
acting
is the crime that she did in a role
different than the crime you observed so
often in the last year of her
relationship with mr duck
yes
inherently acting crying is very
different
unless somebody is working in what's
called method in which
that's an entirely different thing where
they focus on their own stuff
so she's not a method actor so it would
be completely different
speaking for your own
self ms sexton how did you react
when you saw uh amber and pete sessions
crime the way you described it
i have a caretaker personality
so
i would prioritize taking care of the
person in front of me over
doing work which is why i ended up
building in all that extra time because
i cared about her as a human and i
wanted to be there for her and as much
as i could as a friend
so
there's no point on working on something
if someone isn't fully there or they're
upset
it's more important to deal with the
person and take care of them than
work
and during those sessions particularly
in the last year when you saw
her crying so often what was your
understanding
of the reason for her tears
i would hear them fighting and then hear
her come in
and she would be a wreck after she came
in i
i couldn't make out what they were
saying and i personally wasn't trying to
listen to their bites
so i would just hear the sounds of the
screaming
and her usually
she you could tell she would open the
door and try to get him to be quiet and
then it'd go back to him yelling and
um
so
that would directly occur before she
would come down and be
upset and trying to pull herself
together what do you recall seeing her
say she told me that they were fighting
about
i was witness to some of those who
didn't want her going out without
any sort of security or any team he
didn't want her going and doing things
just on her own
you described earlier in your testimony
with sexton what
stanford was like when you first met her
um during this period when she was
involved with mr deaf and particularly
toward the end of their relationship
and her behavior changed
over the course of time she became
more and more of a hermit only leaving
the house when she had to
um
again as i said earlier
literally the house houses became darker
with curtains drawn all the time
um
i remember one time in particular when
we she was living at the eastern
columbia that um we went downstairs to
get a slice of pizza i think there were
four of us um and
amber gave a homeless kid down there
some money and we helped him get to the
bus stop and we came back up and
uh johnny yelled at her
about going out and um
that she knew better than to be going
out at night and that kind of thing
um and when we tried to kind of be like
it's fine we got pizza downstairs at the
building across the street
then he just started screaming and
getting really angry so um
we
i made my way out
what about her weight do you notice any
changes during that period in her weight
just to be clear sex i'm asking about
the time that she was
involved with sister
so amber is one of those people that
loses weight when she's stressed out
um so
she
would drop weight and look skeletal
at a certain point point in time i
remember right before their wedding she
had lost a significant amount of weight
to the point that i was asking her if
she was eating regularly
so
she's always
been fit but she would drop down and get
a little gaunt if she was super stressed
out
and in that last year that she was
involved
with mr jeff you know changes in her
weight
yeah she lost a significant amount of
weight and i noticed it
signifies specifically because
um i had been in australia doing a film
and then when i came back
so i'd been in australia since december
i came back in february
and
she looked uh she was skin and bones
um
like she was much thinner than she
normally was at that point
so i know during that time period that
she had lost a lot of weight and she was
very god
now i'm gonna
shortly move on to specific incidents
but for now
i wanna
and the first question i have in that
regard is
uh
during the time that you were
amber her acting coach and she was
involved with mr that
did you
observe injuries
on misheard
when she came back from australia there
were a lot of like little red marks on
her arms that looked like freshly
healing things
skin like red marks on her skin sorry
um on her arms that i saw
um
and then subsequently i would see like
bruises that look like arms being
grabbed or wrists
um
then i saw that all towards the end
stanford and johnny depp to hicksville
california
yes i went to hicksville
for johnny's birthday celebration
with them
and
um in your own words
can you tell me about that trip and what
happened
chronologically
we
arrived at higgsville and we have made
kind of like a barbecue and drinks
um as
we were having a lovely time
johnny was playing guitar and singing
um
and then as the night went on
uh
like around sundown they started passing
around
a bag of mushrooms and a bag of white
powder
i i didn't even partake in the alcohol
because i had surgery a few months
before so i
was the only one stone cold sober
i
then
i went to bed early
and while my friend and i were in our
trailer and we we heard the fighting
happening
johnny screaming
and a commotion
we didn't come out of our trailer
and then the quieting down and everyone
be like oh it's okay the bodyguards i
heard them running over there
and then the next morning when we got up
the group was talking about what had
happened that night
and then i kind of left that
conversation and went to the trailer to
check on amber
and
i saw the
completely torn apart trailer
johnny was apologizing for what he had
done
and he was instructing his bodyguards to
just pay it off let's just take care of
it
and
i stayed with amber and
she was really shaken up
the next day
can you describe for me what the trailer
where amber and johnny were staying look
like
um the inside was in shambles i remember
seeing a light hanging off the wall
there was broken stuff everywhere
um
dishes it looked like or
not dishes like
the wood was broken things were hanging
off the wall
it was
in shambles on the inside
and that next day
uh
i think you said that you had occasion
to see mr jeff is that correct yeah
how did he look that next day
when he was
he looked very worried he was
apologizing
he was saying he would take care of it
he was trying
he was like don't worry about it babe
we're going to get this taken care of
and amber was
really like closed off and quiet and he
just kept kind of apologizing to her
over and over again
and then telling
his bodyguards to just take care of it
just get it done whatever it is just pay
for it
um
and then he went off to go have that
conversation with them
what was mr jack saying that next day
when he was apologizing
i just remember him saying i'm so sorry
babe i'll take care of it
i i know i know this is bad but i can
take care of it i'm sorry i did this
that kind of thing
i think you said uh testimony but i want
to make sure the record is clear did you
recall mr deck using the word monster
okay
i heard him on different times making
apologies that he said i'm sorry i
turned into a monster
i just remember a profuse amount of
apologies i don't know if that time in
particular had that verbiage
anything else
i mean
the only thing i stated that i did see
him eat the mushrooms i saw him holding
the white bag i don't know what he did
with that the bag of white powder
um
every everyone except for me was
drinking and different people were
partaking in different drugs at that
time
so i didn't keep track of that
yeah i don't know
anything else that i can recall
okay um
i want to
go forward to another incident
and that
is the day of um
april 21 2016
um
which i'll represent to you uh was amber
her city's birthday
um did you have occasion to see him for
her that day
yes i attended the party
um and again
um
you say you attended the park you
described
the party you attended who was there
the party was happening in one of the
penthouses the one that
they didn't live in it's where they did
most of their art and we did most of our
coaching
um
and i don't remember the number of that
one
and there were several friends of
amber's there
and we spent the first couple hours
waiting for johnny
and then eventually amber said just
let's not stop waiting for him let's
just start so we went out to the balcony
to start dinner and that's when johnny
finally came down and
he was severely inebriated when he came
down
and
they uh
brandon
i don't remember his last name it starts
with an m
escorted him kind of helped him stay
stable
and we went to the table and we started
dinner
and
johnny i was sitting two seats away from
johnny johnny and amber clearly were
very tense and had been
i don't know what they had been doing
but they were very tense and
he would try to kind of touch her and
she would shy away um
and then
rocky was trying to change the tone of
the party because it had really gotten
very somber at that point and she asked
everyone to kind of say their favorite
story about amber and as we went around
the table everyone shared their stories
and
when we got to johnny
he started talking about
that he remembered when he first met her
the imprint of amber's ass on his couch
were his words and um
it just all kind of took a turn from
there she was clearly embarrassed she
asked him to stop and he
kept telling the story and
it just it got really awkward and
uncomfortable at that point and
never really
recovered any sort of jovial energy we
ate and then
i left shortly thereafter
i i forgot to ask you this question
about
the day after
uh when you saw
mr jeff and it's heard in
the
the
trailer uh didn't miss her
yeah as i said amber was very closed off
she was very quiet she
she had said don't come in i don't want
you to see this
so yeah she seemed very embarrassed
now switching forward to uh
amber's 30th birthday party i think you
testified that mr
um
that seemed inevitable
what's your basis for saying that
he was slurring his words and wobbly on
his feet he ran into a couple things
which is when uh brandon came over and
kind of locked arms with him to kind of
help them stand up
you said you saw her later with the
healing blooms um what do you recall
seeing that healing bruise on her cheek
it was on her right cheek
i think i think it was
do
right
know how long after the incident that
you just discussed with the cell phone
uh you saw
insured in her face it was a few days
later but i don't i couldn't tell you
exactly when i mean
everyone feels a different way right i
could still see kind of the yellow and
stuff in there so
when was the last time you spoke or you
said august of this year
how did you when was the last time you
spoke together
specifically
you remember
we went over to have i went over it was
sometime in august i can narrow it down
to august
to have wine
and catch up because like i said i think
it had been two years since we've
physically seen each other
both times when you met with ms heard in
august of this year did you meet with
her at her house
yes
did mr mention any of the allegations
that mr death is making against her
in relation to this case when you met
with her
only to say
to talk to the attorneys about it
when you say only to talk to the
attorneys about it
specifically
like she said would you be willing to
sit down and talk to my attorneys about
everything that you witnessed
um
and then afterwards i
after i kind of talked about it all it
felt really intense to me and i felt
incredibly guilty
during one of these two times that you
met with occurred in august of this year
that mr told you for the first time that
mr death had
allegedly raped her with a bottle in
australia
yeah she did talk about the bottle then
yeah
was it the first meeting that you had
in august this year that she mentioned
that
no it was
it was after like i
i'd come to see her and had a wine night
and catch up and then i after i had
talked to the attorneys after we had a
good cry
she we were talking more about
what had happened and
she was saying how she didn't even tell
me and everything
yeah that's when it came out
and just to confirm
told you about the bottle incident in
australia
where she claimed sister death
penetrated her with it
before your definition
your first deposition in space in august
of 2019
uh
yes
it was after i had talked to the
attorneys
after you have spoken to the attorneys
informally correct
yes
but it was before you were formally
deposed in this case
um on i believe it was august 30th 2019.
yes
and just to confirm and make the record
really clear this was the first time the
turd had told you
that mr death had allegedly penetrated
her with a bottle
in australia correct
yeah she had told me about the assaults
with the bottle being hit with the
bottle and the broken glass and
everything
um
and then
she had told me about all that many
times before
and then this time she started crying
and sobbing and started telling me about
the assault
the
creative assault
and when ms heard told you about this
election that occurred
did she know that you were going to be
deposed by her attorney
no because they were all in the other
room
and they didn't even tell me that they
like they were like we may have you for
a deposition
and that's when i had said to them if
you're gonna do that i would appreciate
it if you did it before i left the
states um and they said we may or may
not need you and it was a couple days
later that they then sent me the contact
and said we are going to subpoena you
since you've known can you tell me how
many times you've spent
maybe a significant amount of time with
mr death i would say probably around
like 10 or 20 times i know those 10 or
20 times that you
saw mr death and spent maybe
more significant time than him just
passing through a room
um how many times would you say he was
or appeared to be sober
not many
i he if he was coming down to have a
conversation he was pouring glass of
whiskey or rolling a joint or having
wine
it always seemed to me that
he's not a social
animal
if you will
and he would have a drink or smoke in
order to
go talk to people is what it felt like
but um
so most of the time i saw him it was
that
you would agree with me though mr sexton
that someone getting a drink is
different than someone appearing drunk
correct
for example it was his first drink
of the day so my question's a little bit
more specific
on the 10 or 20 times that you saw mr
jeff how many times did he appear in
inebriated not
you know holding a plot of whiskey or
smoking a joint but how many times did
he appear and degree in a tv i would say
at least half if not more
how would you describe mr duff's
personality when he was or appeared
sober versus when he appeared to be
created he was very quiet when he was
sober and before he would start drinking
he was very quiet
um
almost a whisper mumble most of the time
and then you would get very loud when he
was inebriated and
he would go to like boisterous first and
telling like cool stories and stuff that
kind of happy drunk and then it would
move into the
loud
angry drunk
you say loud and angry drunk did you
witness mr death be angry when he was
drunk
a couple of times yeah
when was the first time you witnessed mr
jen
appeared to be
angry
i couldn't tell you the first time
per se i like i have images in my head
i remember him like yelling and
screaming and the bodyguard coming over
me like hey boss let's let's take this
to another room
can you tell me as much as you can
of that incident
i remember being in the kitchen
of that house
and he came down and he was
yelling about something amber and i were
having a conversation
and we were going to
i think we were going to work on
something that day it was later in the
evening
where it was really dark in there like i
said sometimes i drew all the curtains
in my memory it's very dark um and
he was yelling and
that
older guy
came and like scooped his arm around him
and it's like all right boss let's let's
take this to another place
um
because
he was
inebriated i could tell from the way he
was talking and he was just kind of
yelling and i i don't recall what was
that it all kind of happened very
quickly i don't recall what he was
yelling about or
if it was even at anybody who was just
kind of
down there and drunk and then you
scooped them up
you answered my question asked questions
which were
who was he yelling at and what was he
yelling about so you don't recall is
that correct no i don't
and you said the other instance that you
remember of mr jeff's appearing
initiated and
meaning we was at collected penthouses
in downtown l.a is that correct
what were the circumstances
that you remember about that
i remember one time he was mad um
that people were in the house because i
had just gotten there i don't even
remember
there might have been like two people
there or something i don't remember um
but yeah he was storming up those stairs
to his office bedroom area
um
and then amber and i went to the other
penthouse to work
and in either incident
it's both at squeezer and at the
penthouse
when you saw mr dress and he appeared to
me breathing and was angry and yelling
did you see him
hit his phone at any point
no i did not see him hit her
did you see him kick the turn
i did not see him take her
did you see him throw something after
her
i saw him
coming at her
and that's when the bodyguard stepped in
like coming towards her but i did not
like it so throwing himself at
like but i was not
witness to him throwing objects at her
when you say
he was coming at her are you describing
the incident
or at the penthouse
sweet sir he came in through that
hallway and we were sitting at it was
kind of like an island there
like right in front of the fridge and i
was in front of the fridge and he came
in from there was like coming at her and
then the guy the bodyguard like
came in and scooped him up
this is the incident you don't remember
what mr duff was yelling about or
why yes
but it appeared to you
that
yeah
she was shaking and upset
it felt like something that had been
going on for a while
and all the time that you've known ms
heard and mr jeff
did you ever see mr jeff be violent
towards his heart
i never saw him hit her
i
heard him use terminology as i said
before
and
as i said come at her
but i never saw him hit her
if i had i would have called the cops to
be honest
you never saw mr death
correct
no the only thing i saw was the
aftermath
like i would see things broken
afterwards
um
and like i said in hicksville i heard
the yelling and then saw the breaking
and saw him apologizing for it but i
with my own two eyes did not see him
physically break the stuff or throw the
stuff
when mr jeff and ms heard went to
australia did she tell you that
she threw a bottle of vodka at him and
that fast covered his finger
no no she had told me that he had broken
the bottle and cut himself with a bottle
that he had broken
when she told you that he had cut
himself with a bottle he had broken did
she say that he had
taken the bottle and cut off his finger
or that it was an accident
and that his finger was severed from the
broken bottle
do you understand the distinction yeah
she didn't say that
she didn't indicate that he cut off like
went purposely to cut it
what it seemed to me is that he had
broken the bottle against something and
then he was
doing things with the bottle like
shaking it around and that he had cut
himself from that
it didn't indicate that he had in any
way purposely cut himself
do you recall johnny ever saying
something to you in a conversation with
him later
about his ability to pass insurance
i remember a specific time when amber
still lived at orange and amber was out
with her girlfriends and i had come over
too early for the party so it was just
johnny and i sitting there having some
whiskey and he was smoking cigars
and
he was talking about
that it was
i said something about he said he had to
get up early to do a test and i was like
oh don't you have any sort of
like concern about that and he's like
it's easy to fake insurance tests that's
why we do what we do
i was talking to him because another
client of mine had had to do an
insurance test and he was like oh you
can fake a piss test you can do this
um
and he just kind of went over a few
different ways that it's easy to take
insurance tests and made a joke of it
all right ladies and gentlemen we come
to the end of the the day today so have
a good evening and we'll see you
tomorrow at 9 a.m
again do not discuss the case with
anybody and don't do the outside
research okay have a good evening
all right
do you have any remote witnesses
tomorrow that you need access for
do you need a webex you don't need a web
excellent deposition designations of my
witnesses definition and live witnesses
okay all right that sounds good
everybody knows their homework right
okay thank you all right we'll see you
in the morning
you